so leute ich weiß nicht ob ihr es schon gelesen habt
was ist hier für ne seite gefunden also gefunden ich jetzt nicht so als hätte ich die seite jetzt
irgendwie gefunden ich habe die seite in dem use beitrag gefunden guckt euch das mal an gibt
jetzt hier das erste 5g bioshield revolution das ist ein usb stick da baut um euch quasi so
ein ein schutzschild auf gegen 5g das ist ein usb stick und dass das wird das wird noch viel
besser chat chat ich muss euch refreschen weil ich mal wieder nix sehe natürlich viel besser
scam tribun und wie kommst du denn auf sowas dass das ein scam ist so es passt mal auf was das was
das alles hat also erst mal ist das ein absolutes schnäppchen preis ja also ungefähr 300 315 euro
für einen usb stick der sogar noch wenn ihr hier mal genau guckt der sogar noch hier vorne
ne fucking dalle drin hat wow monkaS der sogar noch ne dalle drin hat und wenn man sich mal
durchliest was die da für tolle für tolle sachen drin haben ja quantum biological shielding
technology ah yes alles klar protecting your family und heune was also was die auf jeden
fall pro teck ist den bank account von den von dem gründer oder gründerinnen oder man weiß ja
heute nicht so genau ja hier proprietäre holo pro pro pro propreterie holo grafik nano layer
technology poggers und das ganze wird natürlich unter anderem durch quanten oszillation
oszillation oszillierung heißt das auf deutsch also quasi schwingungen sowas in der richtung
oszillation würde ich sagen quanten oszillation die das also atome werden wieder in in in takt
in formen wie auch immer gebracht ja und das allerbeste ist dass das kind auch noch lebensenergie
frequenzen ausstrahlt also wahnsinnig big brain ja ja was jetzt hier die römer damit zu tun
an weiß ich auch nicht so genau hier natürlich der weltbekannte dokter ilay laktschek wick
kreis res prof was ein res was moment wir gucken wir gucken erst mal was der typ für
den professor angeblich ist was sind rein res prof was das res prof mean ok research professor gibt sowas ok übelster skammer
salda übelster skammer billige china usb sticks mit so einem komischen durchsichtigen heißkleber
und ran oder was das ist ja und auf was auch immer toll ist auf diese testimonials immer immer immer
am besten das sind die leute die sich wahnsinnig freuen wie toll das ist hier ja thank you so
much after just three days auf bioschild immer aus mal brainfuck entfett die dings auslastung
belastung fertiger für wie spricht man das aus fatigue fatigue spricht man das glaube ich aus
fatigue oder excellent big brain englisch hier also fatigue fatigue ok war richtig fatigue ja
vor allem voll brainfuck kennt ihr das hatte ich auch schon mal brainfuck ich habe irgendwas im
auge habe ich das nervt mich nicht im brain brainfuck und i believe dass das könnte sogar das
könnte sogar wirklich eine richtig echte bewertung sein die ist so fail ja ich glaube es hat einen
positiven effekt der glauben kann man viel wenn der tag lang ist deswegen muss man ja auch bei
allen religionen glauben und nicht wissen es stinkt die gleiche kerbe
ich habe so viele unterschiedliche aus über die jahre ausgebracht ja und das das funktioniert
jetzt schon du es gezockt ja du es ist langweiliger crap guckt euch den mann also meine erfahrung
nur mal so um anzumerken ist ein echter doktor der das schreibt ja ein echter doktor für viele
jahre mit viele jahre erfahrung der aus der der auch wirklich der schon geforscht hat ja und er
hat erwartet es passiert nicht aber dann hat er vergessen dass es da war und dann hat er gemerkt
dass es irgendwie kitzelt ich glaube wie könnte man was heißt auf deutsch kribbeln kribbeln so
was in der richtung hat er gemerkt und und das nur durch diesen geilen usb stick in der
treibung schreibt halb neun und er ist auch zufälliger weise nennt er sich auch dr. d das
dr. d könnte ansthaft den porn name sein oder dr. d olga ist auch am stahl was ein schwachsinn
ey was ein totaler bullshit ich glaube die machen die dinge absichtlich teuer das war doch bestimmt
ich glaube die dinger machen die absichtlich teuer es gibt es gibt ich habe da mal ein video
drüber gesehen ich glaube es gibt sogar studien zu dass wenn man scheiße verkauft dass man die
scheiße teuer machen muss weil wenn die scheiße billig ist denkt jeder es bringt nichts wenn die
scheiße aber teuer ist gibt es welche die sich davon überzeugen lassen product description
auch das sieht schon mal das sieht schon richtig richtig legit aus hier wenn ich das sehe
ja so sieht es dann aus endlich bin ich ich habe irgendwas im auge das ist echt ätzend ja und ihr
seht dass das erzeugt dann eine schutz schutz blase um euch rum zwei schutz blase guck mal da eine
kleine schutz blase große schutz blase was macht die blase in der blase ja das eine ist gegen 4g
und das kleine ist gegen 5g also das große geht für 4g aber gegen 5g ist man dann noch mal
als der kopf noch mal extra abgeschirmt gamer girl badewasser es hilft wahrscheinlich genau
so gut ja so sieht es aus ja übrigens wo wir grad grad bei e-girl badewasser sind kennt ihr
e-girls punkt gg die seite kam ich muss mal gucken ob das noch die seite ist die ich in
dem video gesehen habe ob man die noch aufmachen kann und die seite gibt es nicht mehr die seite
gibt es nicht mehr ok aber aber aber es gibt es gibt noch die die original seite auf die
redirected wurde und zwar das ist keine porn seite bei way es ist es ist das ist keine porn
seite es sieht auf den ersten blick so aus es ist keine es ist keine porn seite man kann das ist
das ist unglaublich beknackt ja wenn man schon immer mal mit einem gamer grill spielen wollte
kann man sich jetzt das game raussuchen also sagen wir mal chat wir wissen ja der chat wir
haben hier viele anime fans am start und die wollten schon immer mal osu spielen und zack
könnte hier auf osu könnt ihr euch leute es gibt nicht nur medels ja könnt ihr euch medels und
und und typen raussuchen die mit euch osu spielen und das kostet dann ein dollar pro spiel was alles
gibt ja die haben sogar die haben sogar voice samples warum du sie mit ihnen spielen solltest
mit mir was sollen alle die wollen die leute die warten nur drauf mit euch was zu spielen ja guckt
euch das an du kannst hier sogar best best bestseller sind das hier guck mal bestseller du
kannst mit xd chill zum beispiel eine runde war so und spielen für ein dollar 50 wenn das wenn das
mal nix ist und das da noch gepaart mit dem 5g schild zusammen da kann eigentlich nichts mehr
schief gehen oder das und 5g dann ist vorbei so was wir heute machen ist folgendes tribo dann ja
gleich sind schlechter stundenlohn ich glaube das machen da sogar wirklich einige nicht wegen
der kohle sondern weil die gerne mit anderen leuten zusammenspielen ja herz 3 90 hat mich
schon auf der seite ein bisschen umgeguckt da gibt es die typen auf der seite haben eigentlich
die lustigsten profile ins korb hat man einige bug ach so hat er mein video zugemacht interessant
und wie war das so hatte dann auch eine runde runde hat ja auch eine runde war so und gespielt
oder was hey max du kennst doch bestimmt diesen ein typ der so ein scammer center gehackt hat
wie ist so was möglich da gibt es ein paar videos zu da gibt es ein paar da gibt es ein paar sachen
zu also zu diesem das ist nicht bestimmt nicht der einzige den du gesehen hast wie so was möglich
ist schwer zu sagen jetzt ohne das spezielle video zu kennen das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an
also die nixos schon mal angesehen war nixos das mit den containers oder bringe ich das jetzt
durcheinander dann hat dann wollten wir uns das mal angucken haben wir aber nicht gemacht
da fällt mir gerade ich muss mein chat mein chat chat log anmachen sonst über sehe ich die
begutigt die big brain questions hier im chat simpher excellent es gibt vor allem wer skip
das web frontend ist ein bisschen kaputt wenn das nicht refreshed macht er irgendwie das
emote doppelt ich mein keck keck weh wird oft verwendet aber ich glaube so oft wurde
das trotzdem noch nicht verwendet im chat dass er quasi in jedem chat in jeder chat nachricht
ein keck keck triple u drinne ist ne das ist ja so viel sind es auch gar nicht aus dem
islul weh größer keck weh ok leute ich ich mache die fragen vom letzten mal weg weil die
wand denke ich mal ziemlich beschränkt auf das letzte mal ja ja ich habe immer noch
keinen beauftragt bei der weh so also was ich uns heute mal angucken ich verfolge das
schon lange dieses projekt ich verfolge das bestimmt schon acht neun jahre lang das gibt
es ja auch schon eine ganze weile guck mal um reacto als release history hier seit 2004
also ich verfolge das schon wirklich lange und ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert weil
ich immer gesagt habe selbst wenn es halbwegs funktioniert wo ist der anwendungszweck von
und das frage ich mich immer noch aber das ist ein oder ist schlecht das ist ein das
ist ein betriebssystem verläuft die reaktion painstrap warum es so heißt weiß ich bring
es gar nicht ja el mustapha sagt es leider nicht so gut ich glaube ich auch man ist auch
schwierig wenn aus nachzubauen und ich ich hatte auch nie vor das auszuprobieren bis
jetzt weil wie gesagt ich habe überhaupt kein anwendungszweck für gesehen und ich
weiß was für ein rumgefrickel ist sachen mit wine zum laufen zu kriegen und das dürfte
hier ähnlich sein aber damals habe ich noch nicht gestriemt und ich habe mir gedacht für
den stream ist es natürlich super geschichte das mal auszuprobieren ob da ob da irgendwas
ob das irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise benutzbar ist und ich meine es hätte ja tatsächlich
seine daseinsberechtigung zum beispiel wenn man software für windows xp braucht oder wenn
es 2000 oder so irgendwas was offline rum steht und nirgendswo verwendet wird wäre das
eine option ja früher früher habe ich mal ich habe einen artikel drüber gelesen dass
die früher reactos und wine sich immer gesüngt haben was apis angeht aber ich glaube mittlerweile
ist es nicht mehr so oft und oder nicht mehr ich weiß nicht und reaktor es sollte wohl
mehr drauf laufen als mit wine und wine ist jetzt halt viel mehr auf auf spiele auch ausgerichtet
durch dieses ganze wie heißt das proton und gedürfnis was es noch alles gibt reagierst
du da jetzt drauf ja quasi das ist dann wirklich reaktion raise schreibt wie wäre eigentlich
wie wäre eigentlich mal ein video wo du genau erklärst worauf eine gute connection bei
games ankommt glaubst du ein ähnliches video hattest du mal da hatte ich schon öfters was
mir gehts vor allem ich hab was im auge und ich krieg das nicht nicht das krieg das nicht
das ist alles so steht eigentlich dieser raketen start heute abend noch space x raketen start
21 uhr 22 gucken ob das noch steht wenn vielleicht gucken wir uns nämlich heute abend im stream
zusammen an was ach nee um genau zu sein 21 uhr 22 sollen die beiden uhr als raumfahrer
bob und duck das sind da die also mehr kokona könnten die leuten ja nicht heißen oder bob
und duck an porta falken also 21 uhr 22 das ist nicht gelaufen das ist heute abend 50
gut update von meinem garten ja warum das so viele leute gesehen haben bis heute nicht
verstanden hast du pollen im auge eher nicht das ist erst seit eine stunde oder so oder
eine halbe stunde ab 17 uhr 15 das gucken wir uns nicht so lang an wir gucken wir machen
vielleicht 20 uhr 30 an und dann gucken wir bis zum start dann ist gut also um nochmal
zurück zu kommen ob das was race gesagt hat mit dem video worauf es bei einer guten connection
bei spielen ankommt ich habe schon jede menge videos gemacht zu dem thema zum beispiel dass
man auch sich dass man dann nicht wirklich viel optimieren kann im endeffekt ja es gibt
so viele guides im internet und wenn ich dann guides sehe wo leute an den windows tcp settings
rum basteln und danach einen ping machen was überhaupt nicht tcp ist da zweifel ich immer
an an an der kompetenz der guideschreiber ja und ansonsten worauf eine gute connection
bei games ankommt im prinzip kommt es eigentlich nur auf zwei sachen auf zwei auf eine sache
kommt es hauptsächlich an dass die verbindung von dir zum surfer schnell ist also schnell
in form von latenz und dass nix verloren geht das war es man muss da gar keine wissenschaft
irgendwie draus machen verbindung von dir zum surfer sollte latenz mäßig schnell sein
fertig hast auch wenig chance dass unterwegs was verloren geht wenn du natürlich massig
pakete verlierst weil unity media wieder scheiße baut dann kannst du auch vergessen darüber
zu spielen das funktioniert nicht richtig so also was ist denn die offizielle seite github
das ist auch schon mal schön startest du noch eine form jaja mache ich gleich das mal gucken
wo es das gibt während der stream hat er erst angefangen also was nix verpasst auch releases
koa die haben richtig viel zipp moment nee nee nee ich will es fokken von react os ich
habe irgendwo install guide gesehen genau hier vor allem blabla blabla installing react
os when creating a new virtual machine choose windows xp professional edition excellent das
machen wir so alpha stage wunderbar wo gibt es das zum downloaden download virtual machines
da wo gibt es denn das iso hier download image file official download page warum ich jetzt
auch heute gesagt habe das könnte man sich echt mal angucken ist weil noch von nicht
allzu langer zeit hier vor ungefähr einem monat ein halbmonat ist die letzte version
rausgekommen download boot cd alternativ ist wir können auch eine live cd wir laden mal
eine live cd runter wollen gerade nichts paying dafür wir wollen es einfach nur mal ausprobieren
okay aber den iso als tipp verpackt das natürlich auch poggers das ist unglaublich wichtig dass
es ein tipp ist naja warum auch nicht hauptsache south forge gibt es noch ja ich wundere mich
auch immer so und dann gehen wir mal installen ja also fassen make sure your thread installing
guide ja das wird ja nicht so schwierig sein oder wir schauen mal die live cd und gucken
uns das an making full backup ja ich installiere es ja garantiert nicht auf meinem system
wir stellen wir starten einfach mal die live cd und gucken an was passiert kann etwas schadet
ja auf jeden fall nichts so new virtual machine was sollten wir aus für windows xp ein betriebssystem
nur zum reaktion ja das extra für unge haben sie das programmiert next so was brauchen
wir windows xp professional soll mal auswählen haben sie gesagt 64 normal und das ganze speichern
wir unter e e vms beste was hat mein wegen der mama halt vor bis 4 ich habe ja noch mehr
und keine ahnung 2 hoffen wir mal dass es reicht 4096 sollte auch reichen naht ich lasse
mal das die fall ich hoffe dass es ergibt ide das habe ich gelesen im install muss unbedingt
ide auswählen weil sata und so haben sie voll noch probleme mit wie wäre es mit winos 98
aber schon gemacht winos 98 haben wir noch im stream schon mal installiert und wir haben
sogar einen halbwegs aktuellen browser gefunden der funktioniert hat es gibt nämlich irgendwelche
verrückten leute die firefox features zurückportieren auf alte firefox und so was aber in gut youtube
videos haben wir nicht abgespielt bekommen vlc leider auch nicht mehr mit youtube die
neuen versionen unterstützen ja keine winos 98 ide create new virtual disc 40 g is ok so
und wir machen an der stelle gleich mit dem printer raus und bei der soundkarte bin ich
mir unschließlich usb lasst wir mal dran finish ok und jetzt wollen wir mal die live cd rein
hier da zack downloads reactos live cd war gespannt ob das überhaupt starten der vm
oh excellent einfach mal live cd mal gucken was passiert ok es startet schon mal das ist
doch mal was gibt es dafür überhaupt vm tools wahrscheinlich gibt es dafür gar keine
vm tools aber man müsste man müsste ja die display settings verändern können es sieht
schon mal aus wie winos 2000 und das hier unten sieht auch aus wie winos wie läuft
ein schmack os in der fremde nachdem die vm nested virtualisiert war lief es richtig schlecht
aber ich installiere es demnächst noch mal in der richtigen vm die nicht nested virtualisiert
ist ok language wir bleiben aber englisch keyboard layout machen aber german an german
run live cd ja wir gucken es erstmal hier da sind wir am start scheiße das sieht wirklich
aus wie winos meine güte dass sie das sieht aber echt acht dass sie da wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr windowy aus ja nested virtualisiert ja ich hatten windows in der
vm laufen und in diesem windows habe ich dann virtualbox installiert und darin dann mac
os weil ich mein host system nicht versauen wollte tatsächlich also es sieht es sieht
äußerst windows mäßig aus es ist so ein zwischending es sieht aus es sieht aus wie
ein kde windows skin nur noch mehr windows ok was ist denn da dabei command prompt na
wunderbar das allerwichtigste sind da linux sachen dabei oder ist das wirklich das ist
wirklich batch hardcore batch und das startmenü funktioniert ziemlich genau man kann hier
auch glaube ich sachen anheften und so wie auch immer was war denn hier oben hier hier
oben waren zuletzt genutzte files nee oder copy ok was was auch immer reactor ok das
ist der explorer ein fake explorer ein papier gut die eiken sehen anders aus das ist klar
die dürfen die microsoft icons ja gar nicht verwenden die dürfen die microsoft das mag
microsoft mit sicherheit nicht ist ein browser dabei ist ein browser dabei communications
remote desktop connection ich brauche einen browser ohne browser ist ziemlicher crap da
kannst du gar nichts machen ok kann man kann man das hier einfach einfach so machen das
ging noch mal unter windows früher search da gibt es ein download tool i can i am robot
hast du schon mal verwendet service system configuration vielleicht nee system in i
mein network places ist nix drinne exzellent oh das control pen also haben sich mühe gegeben
dass es soweit wie möglich an windows 2000 angelehnt ist aber halt ohne die icons read
me notepad ja ok das wichtig das wichtigste ist am start das wichtigste schon mal da tutorial
notepad geht nix nee nee nee sie haben sogar font font smoothing font things clear type
oder wie das heißt irgendwo muss das drüber sein kannst programme nachher sind ja gucken
wir mal settings es haben wir ein netzwerkmenü printer hier das kann man hier das ist wirklich
ziemlich nah dran an dem wie es bei windows 2000 war ist das design nicht von microsoft
geschützt wahrscheinlich nicht die icons aber deswegen haben sie andere icons am start
ist denn das allerwichtigste ist ist mein sweeper dabei ja exzellent das das allerwichtigste
mein sweeper brauma ohne mein sweeper würde es ja überhaupt nicht funktionieren sag mal
gibts da keine bomben drin ich hatte einfach nur mega glück dass ich keine bombe erwischt
hab internet settings ja ich seh keine internet settings system configuration internet settings
tatsächlich
der sinn davon ist dass man windows kompatible sachen ohne windows laufen lassen kann den
sinn finde ich sogar recht eh wie soll ich sagen ehrenhaft ja anwendungszweck für mich
persönlich jetzt nicht wirklich fanden communications ok wie installiert man nach oh ich hab keine
soundcard oder doch hab ich ne soundcard die geht ok was auch immer nee verwende reactor
ist nicht ein teil von geleakte windows court ziemlich sicher nicht das wäre illegal war
das dieses community windows was total gesagt hat es kommt drauf an woran man das mist
so wie installiert man sich den browser das muss ich jetzt das muss ich jetzt rauskriegen
erstmal ok wir haben noch nen ja gut den haben wir unter windows 10 auch ja geh weg ah ok
wie kann man hier sachen weiter downloaden remote desktop entertainment system tools
system tools task manager vielleicht muss man dafür installieren ich glaube man muss
es dafür installieren wir installieren wir installieren das jetzt reboot reboot wir installieren
das jetzt und dann geht das bestimmt live cd im control panel ok installieren wir installieren
trotzdem jetzt mal aber ich würde nicht sagen dass das total gesagt hat weil man darf muss
halt muss halt gucken woran man das mist dass die das nicht eine externe gruppe an leuten
windows nicht besser nachbaut in allen seinen feiern wie microsoft das intern kann ist
ja irgendwie klar also daran kann man es ja wohl kaum messen install excellent perfekt
poggers install geht nicht ok ok ok also dann mal ich mache jetzt mal die auflösung wieder
hoch dass ich wieder was erkenne hier so yes auf screensaver was haben an da das ist ja
echt ich glaube leute es abgestürzt monkeys oder nicht das screensaver dialog ist abgestürzt
ok mal task manager aufmachen oder es lag massive oder cpu last 100 prozent diese windows experience
ist fast wie echter ok ok wir müssen das übliche machen was man windows machen muss
control alt entfernen geht nicht k power reset beim live cd noch mal ok nebenbei gucken wir
mal wie das ganze funktioniert install reactos wir wollen einfach noch vm installieren so
schwierig kann das doch nicht sein oder vielleicht doch ziehe also virtual box for ever workstation
ok idee hard disk haben wir gemacht das haben wir gemacht ok hatten die nicht noch download
react os gab es da nicht noch eine andere cd hier download download boot cd machen wir
mal das south forge wieder ne da stand nicht statt xp da stand drinne man soll windows
xp verwenden choose windows xp wenn man nämlich windows server auswählt dann macht er keine
idee platte und es geht kaputt da steht nicht mal zur server auswählen da steht man soll
windows xp auswählen anstatt server ok hier iso iso iso iso muss man das wieder die cd
auch guck mal die cd die install cd ist größer als die live cd warum das denn ok da machen
wir da waren jetzt noch mal aus aber hier noch mal aus da machen wir jetzt mal die install
cd power off yes excellent iso zack und jetzt mal schauen oh es macht dinger und das war
es sieht wirklich aus wie windows es sieht genauso hässlich aus wie das windows set
up ok moment warte mal ich ich mach euch mal kurz das bisschen ein bisschen größer view
ok ok warum machen sie so ein windows set up weil sie windows nachbauen wollen warum
man das natürlich dann auch noch genauso krass eklig machen muss wie das windows set
up weiß ich nicht enter enter install enter continue reactos alles klar und es ist auch
noch genauso der gleiche der gleiche crap genauso wie f3 zum quitten und so genauso
eklig wie unter windows welches windows soll das nachbilden ich glaube 2003 2003 eins von
bein ich habe vor kurz auf der wikipedia seite geguckt keyboard layout germany german computer
original xbox display na als display hätte ich gerne ehrlich gesagt ist mir egal lass
einfach wie du willst except these device settings ja 40 gigabyte ok erkennt sogar
die festplatte boah sieht das eklig aus fat btrf es hoi hoi hoi hoi jetzt werden sie aber
etwas kommen immer fad das ist mehr windows style set up will now format a partition
fad war nur 4 gigabyte gleich sehen gleich sehen ja ok
das sieht wirklich genauso eklig aus wie windows vom set up und auch dieser reboot dialog
die haben sich wirklich mühe gegeben dass es aussieht wie windows ich mach das jetzt
wie früher ich habe früher auch nie enter gedrückt und habe über 15 sekunden gewartet
ok macht das jetzt automatisch was
ist kaputt ist kaputt ich glaube das ist ribb oder
nicht ok wir machen wir machen mal den stretch wieder aus und starten wir starten nochmal
neu control alt delete macht schon mal nix ok restart enter was wow ah excellent alles
klar funktioniert ja richtig gut ja ich kann da 30 milliarden sachen auswählen aber eigentlich
will ich nur reaktor erst starten ok leute ribb keine chance ok das natürlich enttäuscht
dass du den mal gestartet kriegst ich lass den ich lass den timer noch mal ein time outen
vielleicht darf vielleicht darf ich die enter drücken habe ich beim installen habe ich
beim installieren was falsch gemacht ok dann ist er installiert einfach noch mal das
ist ja kein problem nein ich will die cd starten nein ich will die cd cd cd starten ich muss
schneller sein guck mal ich muss schneller sein zack jawoll excellent einfach mal welche
read me ich hab nix installiert mein read me ok englisch ich machs mal wieder groß
enter ok enter select you for upgrading continue new installation ok ich lass ich lass leute
ich lass alles die fault ich stelle nix um ich lass jetzt alles mal die fault hier f32
perfekt oder soll man bitte fs ausprobieren die lead partition enter l ok bitte fs easy
jawoll ok das ist neu das hatte das winner setup damals nicht ok man die installation
geht ja nur wirklich schnell ne er macht was ok das ist schon mal gut next change system
user lock das machen wir german german german germany geographic locations germany germany
languages ja ok apply keyboard layout das ist ja eins zu eins das windows 2000 zeug
übrigens zu diesem what the fuck what german ja so geht das schon besser dieses menü finde
ich tatsächlich intuitiver als das von windows 10 was passiert hier das ist ein windows nachbau
ich lasse es doch mal lieber standard und format ich will die sprache sprache auf englisch
lassen egal wir machen es mal weiter next owner owner ist gut owner ist cac w reactor
ist tbx u 14 excellent 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 perfekt ja wir sind hier in eigentlich
ist vollkommen egal was wir einstellen wir sind plus plus ich sind wir plus 1713 kommt
sogar hin ist aber tatsächlich noch instabiler wir werden aus 2000 warum wir noch 2000 war
doch relativ relativ so mit classic classic classic es haben wir sonst auch die auswahl
lauthus luna und mit zu der immer classic custom network typical ist ok nein ok restart
das haben sie schon mal bei behalten hauptsache windows restart möglichst oft das macht mir
lang sie haben hier patrick mir auch ein bisschen da ist es da ist es monkaS ok warte mal erst
mal die auflösung kann man wieder hochstellen also was dieser assistent ist ein neugrafik
treiber für milchremedia warnung das installieren von drei man kann ihren pc zum absturz bringen
oder am starten hindern naja wir machen man snapshot würde ich sagen wir machen wir machen
snapshot kann treiber installieren beim gerät konnte nicht also muss sagen die windows experience
ist ziemlich original ja das ist so typischer windows dialog treiber kann treiber installieren
geht nicht oder mehr excellent monaS application manager hier haben wir jetzt sachen hier kann
man zeug nach installieren endlich der adobe flash player gibs mir gibt's mir ich brauch
den flash player abhi wird ok wir installieren erst mal einen browser ist entscheidungsmäßig
vielleicht einer drauf
also installieren erst mal ein browser internet moment was das sind ja firefox firefox version
von jenseits von gut und böse alter firefox 36 firefox 28 und firefox 48
das ist ja das ist antik
egal installieren jetzt opera gaming gab es nur eine zweifel dass der da funktionieren wird
achja klar ich weiß warum das so alt ist wahrscheinlich weil das die letzte firefox
version ist du bin aus 2000 unterstützt hat versuch mal chrome zu installieren kann ich
machen ja wir versuchen gleich ein paar sachen zu installieren also paar sachen die nicht
dabei sind
klingt schon ja da ist aus dem kontext gerissen ist da schon ziemlich der firefox assistent
da ist er wie lange habe ich den nicht mehr gesehen den alten firefox assistent standard
browser firefox starten nichts importieren ja da ist er leute der alte firefox ist wieder
da der mit der oberfläche von winners 2000 jawohl das sieht immer noch genauso kacke
aus wie damals es gibt ja leute die sagen das war besser als heute ich muss sagen ich
finde den aktuellen firefox eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich das ist übrigens nicht das ganz
alte firefox jui das ist so ein zwischending so ein zwischending die hatten schon dieses
die hatten schon dieses komische diese komischen dings rechts klickmenüs hier wobei ich sagen
muss ich finde den neuen firefox vom menü her ganz gut einzige was mich nervt beim neuen
firefox dass die so viele menus haben die man durchklicken muss und also die man nicht
mehr durchklicken kann wie früher hier mit der maus drüber sondern die man anklicken
muss jedes mal firefox update ist verfügbar hat er gesagt ok 48.2 und noch mehr updates
der wills wissen der firefox der wills wissen der geht er geht in die in die vollen er schöpft
aus dem vollen mal gucken was jetzt als nächstes kommt der esr ist glaube ich 68 esr channel
ist gerade firefox 68 ok nächste firefox wahrscheinlich kaputt wahrscheinlich jetzt kaputt guck mal
leute es startet schon nicht mehr es startet schon nicht mehr schon wieder schon rep firefox
ist tot firefox macht nichts mehr also ich würde ja gerne ich würde ja gerne dann ok
das ist typische eklige windows geschichte ich würde gerne einen desktop verknüpfen
firefox erstellen start menu programs ok ich finde nicht mehr die knopf ok leute der firefox
ist tot da geht nicht mehr guck hier rep hat sich erledigt was ist das für ein unterbau ja
nix nix das was eigenes das ist halt windows nachgebaut ok wie entferne ich denn jetzt
den firefox wieder system einstelle und dann software gibt es das hier ok das ist der alte
weg der alte weg wie früher software startet nicht ich kann nix entfernen die software verwaltung
ist kap ok windows windows wie es ist windows ja es ist windows neu start muss oh guck mal
sogar das haben sie drinne press control alt delete login sowas bescheuertes hallo habe
ich doch
ja gut dass wir einen snapshot gemacht haben gut dass wir einen snapshot gemacht haben
ok das ist einmal dreimal dreimal sein so dass wir wissen dass es alles fehlt schlägt
jetzt exzellent was passiert jetzt wenn ich neu starte
kann man dieses press login diese kennt es noch jemand wie man das ausschalten und wenn
es 2000 ok application manager hier 3 options zu disabel wir brauchen ernsthaft windows hacks
dafür im window press windows key plus air run box type net pilwitz ok ah falsche tastatur
net was was mein versteht net pilwitz witz net pilwitz gibt's nicht ok das schlecht microsoft
jetzt erzählt uns wie es geht
ok wir machen wir machen hier den den wir machen wir machen den hack so wie das unter
windows sein muss req edit req edit beste ok wo muss wo müssen wir hin hkcu was software
current user software microsoft windows ist es ja toll dass es heißt current version policies
policies req edit wie sehr sehr nice policies system gibt's da nicht mehr da legen wir
es einfach mal an wie neu ordner die schlüssel ist oder was muss ich anlesen system ich hab
doch gesagt deutsch system disabel mgr dis dis able task mg ajajaj was disabel task mgr
meine tastatur spackt übrigens übelst rum mgr das setzen wir jetzt auf eins what the hell
eins nicht zehn einfach nur aber meinetwegen habe ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben für
den fall der fälle dass das falsch heißt wir machen noch einen neuen schlüssel den
neuen die wort keine ahnung so machen den weg jetzt hat er beides gelöscht wert eins
ok hoffen wir dass es jetzt was bringt so und das nächste ist was wir machen können was
gp edit ist das überhaupt dabei ne den gibt es da nicht ok wir können jetzt nur hoffen
dass es funktioniert also probieren wir mal wir probieren das mal chrome zu installen das
wird im leben nicht funktionieren nie nie ok wir brauchen firefox wir brauchen einen
firefox und wir dürfen ihn nicht updaten wir dürfen ihn auf keinen fall updaten weil
sobald es update geht es kaputt wir dürfen ihn nicht updaten da ist er nicht updaten
kann man das ausschalten die updates irgendwie firefox wir können es nicht ausschalten nein
monka es später neu starten windows was in der letzte chrome der windows 2000 läuft chrome
16 perfekt oldversion.com klingt äußerst jetzt downloaden klingt äußerst vertrauenserweckend
chrome download ok wir können auch den neuesten chrome herunterladen ich glaube nicht dass
es funktionieren wird chrome starten es startet nicht mal der down oh doch excellent animation
ach der ledscher oder nee wow der firefox ist zu alt ich kann kein chrome downloaden
die pop-ups sind zu neu wir laden das einfach von chip runter ok chrome chip
wir können es auch auf computer bild machen ja 64 spit ob das so eine gute idee ist ist
das ist das 64 spit oder ist was ist denn das 32 spit 64 spit das erkenne ich hier draus
nicht ist es ein 64 spit bild 32 spit bild weiß nicht du hattest wenn aus xp professional
32 ausgewählt ja in der vm das ist egal hallo don ah guck mal da der chip installer will
ich wirklich den chip installer ich will nicht den chip installer ich will mir einfach nur
einfach wie laden wir 32 spit chrome runter der chip installer download jawoll gib alles
komm go go go ich muss erstmal addblock installieren klick hier poggers das funktioniert gibt es
noch eine alt block block für firefox 48 gibt es noch was altes ich brauche noch einen
alten block mindestens 51 was soll das piss dich alle saurei ok wo ist der download ordner
da standard chrome setup startet nicht ich habe nichts gesagt ich habe nichts gesagt
leute oder doch leute mein rechner hat gerade übelst übelst hoch gedreht den lüfter ey
oh ok geht nicht dann installieren wir doch den alten chrome den wir gerade runtergeladen
haben chrome chrome installer 16 excellent den installieren wir jetzt hallo öffnen
ok soll ich mal riskieren neu zu starten kommt abschließend probieren ob der firefox sich
update wieder ich muss neu starten mal mit diesem kack voll ab kommt mal hier also immer
ich ich wollte den chrome installer starten den all guck mal hier das geht schon gar
nicht mehr das ist voll kaputt ok leute es ist vorbei jetzt ist er wieder kaputt er läuft
noch er läuft noch vielleicht war auch das problem dass er noch lief wir schießen jetzt
einfach ab und starten die neu da ist er macht auch was ok kann man die sachen drüber
installieren man kann ihn drüber installieren das natürlich auch toll firefox muss beendet
werden das ist ja die volle windows experience hier die funktioniert ja unglaublich gut
alles chrome hat er hier glaube ich nicht drinnen probieren chrome ha da sind wir wieder
am start ok also die sache ist die die alte der alte chrome installer der funktioniert
nicht der startet erst gar nicht das ist kann man schon mal voll vergessen ok da ist er
chrome installer zack kack da mag nicht na gut what the fuck ok was gibt es den sonst
noch auszuprobieren also firefox dürfte auf keinen fall abdecken sonst verreckts so was
haben wir was haben wir sonst noch was gibt es sonst noch internet und netzwerk k-melon
das ist auch ein browser den kann man noch mal ausprobieren opera ok die ural oder otter
utter putti gewinnt sich noch k-melon mirc ist auch am start ja boah das ist ja noch
antiker antiker browser alter monka da läuft ja gar nichts mehr mit oder doch ok ok youtube
die das layout ist deutsch ok das mag er nicht das weiß ich jetzt schon das wird er
nicht machen please update your browser remind me later ich weiß easy kein problem update
your browser ach was ich wollte jetzt schon immer hier mal das da woodturning mir angucken
das wird aber nicht laufen leute ja der kann kein html5 video ich komm jetzt ohne scheiß
leute ich mir kommt das vor als ist es kaputt 90 dr co stimmt leute ich muss neu starten
das leckt mega das ist das ist voll am abkack ich starte jetzt neu ansonsten haben wir nix
wir haben ja nix großartiges verpasst ich kann fast snapshot restore und dann sind wir
wieder da und dann ist gut leuchter ok leute mal gucken ob es geht guck mal da starte nicht
mal richtig neu ah jetzt monach s hat er den snapshot restored
hat er gerade einfach den snapshot restored kann das sein oder kommt es jetzt jedes mal
ne firefox ist noch da ok ahja alles klar ganz ganz toll ok was gibt es
ansonsten auch für applications 7 zip haben wir hier abhi wird bis web server was auch
immer flash warum gibt es das hier zweimal flash ok installieren wir jetzt erstmal hat
das was gebracht mit dem firefox starten was das ist keine neue version oder ist das eine
neue version ne da sind wir noch 48 und das wird das wird abkacken wieder please select
language englisch ja top abhi wird abhi wird brauchen wir immer das schmerzt ja ok das
das ist echt ui aus dem letzten jahrtausende man kann alle ich kann ja nicht mal schreiben
ok was so ich will einfach nur schreiben ich will einfach nur schreiben das funktioniert
echt hinten und vorne nicht ok oder der flash player der flash bei den brauen natürlich
noch high speed download sehe ich hier oh wie lange habt ihr das schon nicht mal gesehen
ich glaube das habe ich 20 jahre nicht mal gesehen oder so na vielleicht nicht ganz
das jetzt übertrieben zehn jahre habe ich das nicht mehr gesehen nie updates suchen
das ist besser ok geht jetzt flash im firefox was ganze spiele affe gab es auch da früher
war das spiele affe spiele affe genau flash ist flash installiert gleich mal gucken moment
wo sah man auch mal die addons shockwave da ist es genau wir müssen jetzt unbedingt
agar ios spielen ja
ist es flash boah wie das oh wie das leckt
like w play oh wie das leckt ach du scheiße
computer is running slow machwitz das ist oh das ist hardcore kaputt das ist huge kaputt
fünf frames ja ok was haben wir sonst noch so audio brauchen wir alles nicht audacity
ja winamp winamp winamp winamp winamp lama irgendwas mit lamas kam dann
excellent kaputt video vlc ok welche ver welche vlc version kriegen wir hier vlc 3 das ist
doch gar nicht so alt oder kann das sein dass das sogar relativ neu ist schaust du
die ps5 stream nächste woche an wann ist der wann ist der ok das sieht doch ziemlich alt
aus so alt ist das gar nicht wenn wir glück haben wenn wir glück haben kann der vlc youtube
abspielen donnersdag ok das muss man gerade mal aufschreiben donnersdag ps wie viel
stream moment hat das abdecknetz funktioniert der firefox ist einfach nur die schrift größer
geworden aus nicht näher verständlichen gründen ist einfach nur die schrift groß geworden
vielleicht haben wir glück vielleicht haben wir glück und ich kann ein youtube in youtube
video vlc abspielen das ist wirklich dass ich dass ich es ist es ist fast schlimmer
als wenn das 98 ok voll z striemen netzwerk striemen was nein netzwerk öffnen so war das
genau wiedergabe wer auch zu schön gewesen das wäre auch zu schön gewesen wäre das funktioniert
moment man kann es ist es flash nähe das ist ein html 5 video eben hat er noch gemerkt
der kanker hatte immer in 5 hier high performance bettel viel gameplay guckt euch das mal an
ja jetzt flutscht aber vor allem audio treiber das müssen wir jetzt machen excellent
fack und dahin ah ja das da
ok jetzt muss ich meine windows skills wieder wie hat man hier überhaupt noch treiber aber
als platzgeräte manager war das ne device manager verwalten genau das ist so ne kein
nix drinne wo ist der device manager die weiß die weiß manager die weiß manager multimedia
die weiß jetzt gleich haben wir sound leute gleich haben wir sound oder auch nicht oh
fack wie ging das denn ich treiber manuell auswählen geht nicht guck mal ob twitch läuft
probiere ich gleich aus vielleicht muss ich auch hier hin oder dahin wie so vielleicht
vielleicht dahin mein inf ist immer gutes des windows ok hat es jetzt funktioniert
hallo ich bin die freshen wie ging das hier refresh f5 da ist das leute audio treiber
ist am start was zum teufel ist das reaktor ist das ist ein windows nachbau
keine geräte hätte ja fast funktionieren können neu starten ok warum sollte man windows
nachbauen wollen das weiß ich nicht aber das haben die leute gemacht stimmt wir müssen
gucken ob twitch funktioniert also youtube funktioniert in bisschen welche auflösung
gibt es denn jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob es nicht komplett verreckt naja naja komm
also ich mein es läuft nicht wirklich aber ich meine es kackt nicht ab ok stoppen kann
ich nicht zack ok ob twitch läuft twitch tv wo blots nein wo blots das hat man wieder
die tastatur hast du schon neuen bios dick gekauft ja dreier pack komm mal mein twitch
stream funktioniert twitch hat lange flash noch verwendet ja feels bad man twitch twitch
geht nicht twitch ist kaputt paper hands ja erstmal neu starten aber vielleicht wartet
mal vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht netzwerk stream öffnen hat ttp doppelpunkt ob es
nicht ich kann twitch punkt wie wo blots exzellent also http s doppelpunkt doppelslash ok neu
starten heustaten hilft immer nutz reaktor ist ein paket manager ja so was ähnliches
nur dass es mehr oder weniger haltenden binary downloader ist und die sachen entzippt hat
er jetzt was erkannt vielleicht habe ich einfach auch die falschen sound settings aber
so in ein paar war schon mal ohne sound top der übrigens nicht startet beide weine firefox
oh ich habe nichts gesagt ich habe ich habe nichts gesagt ich habe nichts gesagt sending
user information nein skip da ist er der gute alte klassiker schlechthin und wir können
auch nicht mal den sound abspielen das weckt echte erinnerung du verwendest immer noch
wenn ich schon ewig nicht mehr ich habe mittlerweile nur noch vlc aber was gutes ich kann hier
auch mal einem tick nachgehen seht ihr es firefox investment starten firefox hat den
geist aufgegeben firefox geht wieder nicht mehr ist das kaputt das update wurde installiert
ja wahrscheinlich ok es ist halt wirklich absolut unbenutzbar jetzt ist wirklich es
ist legit komplett unbenutzbar also was haben wir ja ja ja wichtig das brauchen wir super
machen für den 60 backgrounds allerwichtigste überhaupt haben wir eine tartei viewer ja
aber ich meine tartei viewer ok extra hier auf dem desktop wo sonst es können nicht
mal mehr sachen extrahiert werden ok es ist wirklich es ist wirklich mega im arsch alter
owl instant messenger ich glaube sich alter net framework zeug treiber ah den den könnten
wir auch noch installieren sound blaster treiber für fmw ich glaube wir müssen den
installieren wir das an die virtual box ok fack cc what sehr gutes bereinigungswerkzeug
für den pc ja exellent den brauchen wir unbedingt da ist all das der cc cleaner ist
drauf ich fasse es nicht da ist er und der funktioniert auch ja da kann nichts mehr schief
gehen endlich weiß die auslastung von meiner festplatte new version is available das glaube
ich keine so gute idee was seit wann habe ich da den internet explorer drauf wo kommt
der auf einmal her wo kommt denn der internet explorer auf einmal her und und und warum
ist es der weitenden explorer warum kackt die ganze fm gerade ab jetzt ist vorbei leute
jetzt vorbei ripp ripp vorbei jetzt vorbei ok restart er ist keine
ahnung wahrscheinlich keine denke mal keine treiber automatisch installieren er ist ganz
scharf drauf oh der desktop geht nicht mehr leute es ist kaputt es ist komplett kaputt
oh nein doch nicht da ist es ja wieder auf einmal war es wieder da ok es ist es ist echt
unusable ok wir brauchen den browser der funktioniert firefox hat hat kein bock mehr genau ich muss
darauf unbedingt was entwickeln ich will noch gucken ob notepad plus plus geht ok das probieren
das probieren so aus dak dak go ok perfekt ok notepad not notepad plus plus don't know
was ist das überhaupt für ein interface das ist ja das hässlichste browser interface
aller Zeiten das sieht mega eklig aus englisch next agree next läuft notepad plus plus wenigstens
oh da macht was es macht was habt ihr gesehen es hat was ausgeführt also wenn noch nicht
mal notepad plus plus läuft dann ist dann ist echt was faul ah excellent notepad plus
ok was gibt es sonst noch so gibt es etwas was wir noch ausprobieren könnten wartet
mal ich habe die idee leute ich habe mir ich habe steam das ich wollte es kann sagen ich
wollte auch gerade sagen steve steve das wird halt im leben nicht funktionieren haben
eine mysql datenbank warum kann ich machen ok wenn es wenn es eine mysql datenbank wenn
du eine mysql datenbank haben willst ok mysql windows oder gab es das hier oder gab es
das über die developer tools entwicklung was haben wir hier zu bieten codeblocks git
jit jit vor windows paskal win hier wir brauchen was für winos 2000 winos 2000 download ok erst
mal gucken ob wir steam installiert kriegen was halt garantiert nicht der fall sein wo
ist in diesem komischen crap browser überhaupt wo sind hier die downloads wo sind hier überhaupt
download was denn gui was denn gui das ist ja das schreckliche gui als das schrecklichste
guis die ich je gesehen habe tools vielleicht macht es das hier steaming ok englisch steam
run nein steam geht natürlich nicht das hätte mich aber auch echt gewundert wenn steam geht
es kackt voll ab geht nicht mehr leute kein steam ok my mysql winos 2000 download gibt
es da noch was discord discord discord könnte im firefox hätte discord wahrscheinlich funktioniert
aber firefox startet ja nicht mehr und in diesem komischen was auch immer es hier ist
geht discord wahrscheinlich nicht ok da bin ich jetzt echt mal da bin ich jetzt echt mal
gespannt der browser ist so schlecht der kann auch nicht mal captures lösen ach du große
neune gibt's pinball nee es gibt nur mein sweeper aber ja es gibt nur mein sweeper firefox
ich habe doch gar kein firefox gestartet warum ist der firefox wie kann firefox abkacken
wenn ich firefox gar nicht gestartet habe man kann auch nicht mal captures hat ist das
ein crap alter ich muss ich muss los ich muss echt los weg ich halte es immer aus geh weg
nee nee leute nee man muss man muss sich echt nicht alles geben oder
weg das war zu anstrengend das war das war echt zu anstrengend wer hat es eigentlich
im startmenü erlaubt sich sich vor mein overlay schieben zu dürfen erst mal gucken wie viele
wie viele wie viel mehr wir uns auf unserem haus eingefangen haben ja keine aber es sieht
ja alles sauber aus aber das ist ja so kaputt das hätte ich nicht gedacht ich hätte gedacht
dass bei der software also was war seit 2004 in entwicklung ist dass so die basics funktionieren
oder wie man aktuell sagt die basics ich kann das nicht aussprechen richtig funktionieren
machts aber nicht nee nee nee nee leute nee echt nicht es muss nicht sein wisst ihr was
wir installieren jetzt echt das windows xp windows xp iso download das habe ich schon
ewig nicht mal gemacht einfach nur weil es geht es hat keinen es hat wirklich keinen
sinn was war sp3 war das letzte archiv hier nee was sp2 windows xp sp2 oder wieso benutzt
du eigentlich kein linux mache ich doch easy linux powers das board geht nicht windows
xp last service pack was war das 3 ok also was haben wir hier download jawoll gib her
i like it so much des windows xp version found some keys iso image download excellent jetzt
also ich benutze eigentlich nur henna montana linux und windows natürlich
wir haben es alle nicht gecheckt und es hat funktioniert wir haben es bloß nicht gecheckt
Richtig Windows
Okay da brauchen wir auch kurz ey also ich habe ja nicht damit gerechnet ich habe ja
Ehrlich wirklich ich habe nicht damit gerechnet dass da irgendwas rauskommt wo ich dann am ende sage ja das kann man sinnvoll
Für, was verwenden aber dass es so kaputt ist
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht weil es ist es ist nicht einfach nur so kaputt es ist es ist so kaputt also
Es geht ja gar nicht ich kann auch nicht mal in einem text editor
eine zeile schreiben und dass der bildschirm die ganze zeit hin und her springt dabei
also das ist
3 windows alternativ ja ganz bestimmt
Ja paint haben wir uns gar nicht angeguckt total sinnloser shit
Also
Übrigens die
Die space x start war ja heute irgendwie 21 22 ich glaube nicht dass ich so lang und bleibe ne also ich
Ich komme da noch mal an
Also ich glaube nicht dass ich jetzt bis
Das meine sind noch drei stunden soll drei stunden noch machen
Läuft obs eigentlich mit reaktor os
Also wenn ich mir angucke dass im endeffekt fast nichts mit reaktor es läuft mit der obs nicht laufen
Ist reaktor es nicht mehr oder weniger so ein ein mannprojekt oder verwechsel ich das jetzt gerade
Ich meine für den ein mannprojekt ist es schon nicht schlecht dass es überhaupt bootet und und geht und
Aber wirklich für
Man kann es noch nicht mal für spieler rein verwenden um einfach nur zu gucken ob es geht oder nicht
Nicht mal für spieler rein verwenden um einfach nur zu gucken ob es geht einfach gar nix
Was kein sub alert ist es kaputt
Echt also vorhin ging es noch ich sehe aber auch im chat gar kein gar kein gar keine sub alerts
Es ist ich glaube die sub alerts sind gerade also falls also huge big brain subscription wenn du grad abonniert hast
Aber ich glaube twitch wenn du wirklich gerade abonniert sind sind die alerts gerade kaputt
Warum kann man die nicht spenden weil der spenden link kaputt ist deswegen habe ich ihn entfernt
Einzige was ich sehe hier der in der sub re-subscriber die kautz hat re-subscriber
Re-subscribed vor zwei stunden ich glaube das habe ich nicht gesehen
Natürlich fail dankeschön falls noch am start bist
Und ansonsten sehe ich hier nix
Aber heute heute will ich euch noch mal zeigen wie mannprojekt oder spieler ein mannprojekt oder spieler ein
Und ansonsten sehe ich hier nix aber heute heute will ich auch gar keine großartigen subs also heute heute heute nicht
Subscriben letztes mal gab es schon so viele so viele subs das war ja nicht normal das muss ich jetzt erst mal alles wieder einpeddeln
Sonst muss ich ja wirklich irgendwann auch steuererklärungen upgraden wegen dem kram hier
Das wäre nicht auszudenken
Knäher bär ja aber die notifications waren kaputt
Machst du den github link in dein twitch profil noch mit rein das ist eine gute idee das kann ich machen
Github wo blorts
Das kann ich machen
Max exe sechs monate poggers dankeschön prime subscription
Das ist eine gute idee das mache ich jetzt echte mal ich mache gerade mal mein
Mein github profil in die channel beschreibung das war nicht nicht verkehrt das ist eine gute idee das hätte ich schon die ganze zeit mal machen können absenden
So ist drinnen
Letztes ja letztes mal hat der patrick unter tainsall ging voll ab die haben ihr subs verschenkt ohne ende
Ach das ärgert mich also ein bisschen enttäuscht hat mich da kram jetzt schon ja dachte zumindest für kleine für so kleine spielereien ist das eigentlich ganz witzig hier
Aber es funktioniert ja quasi
Was das
Assault cube
Big brain game ja was ist das
Big brain game ja emulator zeug und so aber da brauche ich doch kein reaktor erst für
Ah nee das ist doch das ist blöd
Da hauschmerzen winos xp drüber da habe ich das originale poggers
Poggers
Guck mal gleich dauer 21 sekunden ist fertig ist winos xp still usable
Usable ist es noch ich will nicht wissen wieviel geldautomaten wir noch 6p haben gab es eigentlich noch paar frage
Ich habe leider dass das mit dass das logging zu spät angemacht also die hälfte vom stream hat es gar nicht auf aufgenommen
auf aufgenommen
Ja brauche echt was nein wozu ich habe genug
Ja es waren es waren im letzten stream waren es über 100 subs in unter zwei stunden
Der hams ist voll übertrieben mit dem letzten stream okay ist er dauernd fertig poggers jawoll
So wo ist mein cd laufwerk da dauernd winos xp ja exzellent
Und wo ist mein cd laufwerk wo ist mein cd laufwerk wo ist mein cd laufwerk
exzellent
Oh nee da ist er der shit wieder geh weg da cd
Der gute winos installer da ist er da ist er lange nicht gesehen
Der richtig echte funktionierende winos installer ist am start
Ja
Ob man überhaupt vor mw tools noch unter winos xp installieren kann
Okay continue i agree stimmt es gab ja noch die zentzbedingungen
Die lead selected partition ja enter l jawoll ntfs quick
Der installer ohne skammer ist ja der funktionieren wenigstens
Ich habe wirklich seit ich winos xp deinstalliert habe auf meinem desktop rechner ich habe das system nie wieder gehabt
Und winos xp war so war war eine zeit wo es wo es auch wo wo ich auch sehr viele
positive erinnerungen an
Sachen habe die ich da auf dem desktop rechner gemacht haben ja sei es nur damals mmos gespielt es war alles winos xp zeit
Ja, sei es nur damals mmos gespielt es war alles winos xp zeit
Zeit
Ich habe früher immer erkannt
Und ohne da oben zu gucken wie weiter ist anhand was für dateien gerade kopiert werden
Das war ja eine zeit wo man winos noch öfters neu installiert hat ja nicht so oft wie zu winos 98 zeiten
Aber trotzdem auch auch oft noch
Restarting jawoll gib mir gibs mir
Ah jetzt das ist das kommt er noch bekannt vor
Das kommt er noch bekannt vor jawoll mal gucken wie lange es wirklich braucht
Mal gucken wie lange es wirklich braucht ich tippe auf sechs sieben minuten
Warum musste man das neu installieren
Weil man sich eingebildet hat man kriegt einen schnelleren rechner wenn man winos öfters neu installiert
Also das waren ja die zeiten vor allem winos 98 aber auch später noch wenn es dort irgendwelche backs gegeben hat was nicht
Richtig funktioniert hat das erste was du gemacht hast ist winos neu installiert
Oder rechner hängt rechner back drum was auch immer winos neu installiert
Und man hatte da schon quasi fast eine
Eine religiöse ausprägung in welcher reinfolge man
Programme installiert hat und wie man in welcher reinfolge was angeklickt hat weil man sich eingebildet hat
So ist die beste variante der rechner ist danach am schnellsten
Die ein oder andere werden es noch kennen ich gebe bin ziemlich sicher dass ich nicht der einzige war
Und was unter winos xp richtig cool war weil die styling möglichkeiten zu style xp und so was es da alles gab das können
Wir gleich mal ausprobieren
Das ist so viel geiler als winos 10 was styling angeht
Die winos xp cd lag dauerhaft im laufwerk er ja ja weil ich hatte damals drei laufwerke
Ich hatte einen brenner das war so ein brieb brenner
Dvd laufe noch ein altes 48 fach cd laufwerk ich hatte drei laufwerke drin und in dem in dem einen lag immer oder fast immer
Die winos xp cd richtig
So da sind wir hier
Details ich hätte gerne ich hätte gerne die voll in putt language ich hätte gerne
german
German Germany yes und den will ich löschen
excellent was
Ja ja alles klar wenn du hast es mir vollkommen wurscht machen was du willst next name test
oh
Monkeys das habe ich ja ganz vergessen
um
Okay
Ich weiß nicht wie legal das ist ja ich habe keine ahnung wie legal das ist ich mache ich mal kurz aus
Und wir tippen ich tippe mal da was ab
Was ich natürlich legit hier bei mir liegen habe ich tippe das von einem originalen
Windows xp lizenz sticker ab natürlich
Ich hoffe ihr würdet jetzt auch nie was anderes vermuten. Ja
Na geiler lizenz key geht nicht ich eingegeben habe dann ist mein lizenz sticker
Geht nicht. Ich habe ein lizenz sticker
Geil der lizenz key geht nicht. Ich eingegeben habe dann ist mein lizenz sticker wohl falsch
Keck dribble you
Ja es wird sich doch irgendwo doch ein gültiger lizenz sticker finden
Okay geht der hier
So einen brauche noch
Ja ich habe noch einen gültigen lizenz sticker gefunden leute
Braucht man administrator konne braucht man nicht
Zum glück habe ich auch einen lizenz sticker gefunden leute das war echt zwar echt knapp
Okay was haben wir hier germany
Ja
Wie oft ich diesen installer gesehen habe das ist echt nicht mehr normal collecting information seit windows 10 nimmt das microsoft wörtlich
Und
Oh
Ja die allseits beliebten microsoft progress button typical settings workgroup. Yes
Stay up to date windows update provides with critical software updates das probieren wir ob das funktioniert
Klein noch das probieren wir gleich aus ob windows update noch funktioniert
Bestimmt nicht das haben die bestimmt abgeschaltet
Das das ist garantiert fake installing start menu items das ist garantiert fake was hier steht warum sollte der für 15 links
eine minute brauchen das ist garantiert fake die haben da einfach irgendwas hingestellt die haben irgendwas
Hingeschrieben einfach dass es so aussehen als wird es was tun ich ich ich wette drauf ich
Ich bin da immer noch heute von überzeugt dass das was hier steht
absolut nichts damit zu tun hat was es wirklich macht
Die echte xp update experience spaß für tage ja
Man hatte ja damals oftmals nur eine windows xp cd dann musste es der erst mal sp2 installieren sp1 oder sp2 ich weiß es gar nicht
mehr oder weniger fast neues betriebssystem
Latest hardware und software da bin ich ja da bin ich ja froh
Microsoft hat hat hat uns hier
Hat hat our back ja microsoft die guck mal die supporten sogar die
vd ram drives
Und zip disk
Das ist ja unglaublich was die alles machen
Felix sagt hallo halb im chat gesagt das geht noch habs vor einem jahr mal gemacht das sehen wir sehen wir gleich gleich sehr fertig
Okay es wird ernst es wird ernst monaq s
Da ist es das richtig echte originale
Da
ok es wird ernst es wird ernst monac s da ist es das richtig echte originale ja mach
das mal excellent hat es ja viel getan ist jetzt anders als vorher nee oder
es sieht auch nicht aus anders aus als vorher hat man kurz
aber die uhr geht das ist schon mal was please wait oh welch multimedia
das ist quasi cortana von windows xp ok das ist das ist echt dass ich habe es
glaube ich noch nie durchgeklickt thank you for purchasing next soll ich aber
eins eins muss ich muss ich mal wirklich sagen mir persönlich hat diese luna
geschichte dieses luna interface oberfläche von windows xp bisher mit
abstand am besten gefallen windows 7 war wohl war auch noch ganz ok aber das
ganze look und feel von xp hat mir bisher am besten gefallen
help protect ja nein ja nein es war von hand gleich ich mein objektiv objektiv
gesehen sieht natürlich wenn aus zehn im jahr 2020 mehr aus wie 2020 ja keine
frage ist ist so aber das hatte irgendwie so was eigenes ja ja ja next
nein username hat man das nicht grad schon test thank you ok
windows 8 90 es kommt auch der nächste der sagt er fand window ist das dich
bisschen verschoben das logo der nächste sagt er sagt bist aber am besten ja jetzt
da sind wir da sind wir habe ich das lange nicht mehr gesehen
ey monka es habe ich das lange nicht mehr gesehen hier
das habe ich ewig nicht mehr gesehen oh ne ordentliche auflösung geht
anscheinend nicht jetzt das habe ich ja ewig nicht mehr gesehen
windows xp so in da guck mal wie schnell alle wie schnell das ist
wtf das ist 30 mal schneller als als windows 10 in der vm
komm ich sehe das ist der fack
take it to ok haben wir haben wir eigentlich audio haben wir audio
wir haben audio kann das sein dass die soundkarte nicht richtig
eingestellt ist dass er den falschen soundausgang nimmt
sollte er sollte er jetzt was machen
sollte er jetzt nicht sound haben oder so
der sollte eigentlich sound haben da aber so immer und er sollt der hat auch
damals schon bling bling gemacht bling bling bling macht aber nicht das habe
ich so lange nicht mehr gesehen ohne scheiß ich habe das seit ich vor meinem
desktop als ich vor meinem desktop runter geschmissen habe habe ich das nie
wieder nie wieder mir angeguckt wenn aus xp ok ob wir uns das trauen können
mal update wie ging der windows updates noch security center wie hat man auch
mal updates von hand gemacht updates
keine mehr akte heute in dem stand doch der neben stand doch gerade
wenn aus update und in der explorer heute monac es ich sehe hier links was
verweht aus updates das ist das ok das funktioniert automatik updates easy easy
get get kein problem ok wie kriegen wir da jetzt funktionieren
dann wie kriegen wir da jetzt funktionierenden firefox ok und last
last version firefox windows xp
ok 52.9 esr 52.9 esr oder 52.9.0 esr download yes da ist er ok
ich glaube das spackt einfach nur um das hatte tps geht ja nicht mehr
am
wie kriegst duArin jetzt überhaupt irgendwas
Was ist mit dem Explorer jetzt überhaupt irgendwas?
Probieren wir mal, ob der funktioniert.
Chip geht bestimmt noch, ne, okay.
Veräumertools, hast recht, Veräumertools ist die einzige Chance, die wir haben.
Install Veräumertools, exzellent.
Ach guck mal, es gibt Updates! Es gibt Updates, Leute!
Habt ihrs gesehen, da unten? Updates waren am Start.
So richtig, richtig, echt, so Windows XP Updates.
Ja, Moment, da hat doch da irgendwas von FDP geschrieben.
Gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass man anstatt, ah, geh mal weg.
Dass man, ah, jetzt nervt mich rum, dass man hier mal FDP.
Ich darf nicht tippen. Ah.
Was bin ich sehen, Windows XP?
Okay, darf ich jetzt da tippen?
FDP, FDP.
Ne.
Gehst du? Gehst du?
Okay, neustart, yes.
Ach, das war, also ich hab echt gute Erinnerungen an Windows XP.
Ohne Scheiß, Windows XP, da hab ich so viele geile Sachen drauf erlebt im Nachhinein.
Also jetzt nicht geil im Sinne von, ihr wisst schon, ne?
Also, ja.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Moment.
Das waren coole Sachen.
Warum kann Vmware, warum kann die Vmware Tools das nicht mehr? Vmware Tools, please.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt. Ah, excellent.
Your computer might at risk.
Wir müssen noch Avira, Avira installieren wir als nächstes, äh.
Ach, das ist so, das ist so.
Avira müssen wir noch installieren.
Okay, kann ich jetzt Dragon droppen?
Probieren wir mal kurz aus, ob ich jetzt was Dragon droppen kann.
Irgendwas.
Okay, funktioniert. Excellent.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt hier downloaden.
Firefox, was war das? 52.9.0 ESR.
Da.
Windows XP, wo ist XP?
Windows, Windows 546, Windows 32.
Äh, Englisch.
Kona.
Hier.
Der müsste Windows XP noch unterstützen.
Bonsibar, oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das war dieser komische Affe.
Genau, nee, nee, nee, nee, kann ich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Okay, da sind wir.
Excellent.
Oh, es scheint zu funktionieren.
Monkeys, Firefox Installer.
Next, next.
Da geht was.
So sah das damals also aus.
Ich kann mich da echt nur noch dunkel dran erinnern, ja.
Ah, cool.
YouTube.
Es ist sogar halb, es ist sogar halbwegs schnell und bedienbar.
Okay, das ist das, das ist das.
Sogar Videos funktionieren.
Aber das Sound geht immer noch nicht.
Hot Comic.
Meine Stiefmutter ist nur 10 Jahre älter als ich.
Alles klar.
Was geht da hinter SpaceX?
NASA Streams.
SpaceX.
Zeig mal hier YouTube.
Hier.
Ah, die steigen jetzt erst ein.
Nein, haben wir noch Zeit.
Okay, das funktioniert doch schon mal erstaunlich gut.
Ist das Flash? Nee, ist Windows.
Guck mal, sogar das 1080p Video geht.
Es geht echt ziemlich gut.
Guckt euch das mal an, das ist sauflüssig.
1080p Video in AVM läuft besser als in Windows.
Leute, das läuft besser als in der Windows 10 VM.
Das läuft besser als in der Windows 10 VM, das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Guck mal, wie flüssig das läuft.
1080p 60FPS in AVM überhaupt kein Problem.
Geht richtig flüssig ohne jegliche Probleme.
Was ist 1044p?
Ah, nee, nee, nee.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, das war gar nicht.
Na ja.
Doch.
1044p 60FPS in der Windows XP VM.
Guck mal, wie schnell das geht.
Da kannst du dich nur wirklich nicht beschweren.
Okay, was brauchen wir als nächstes?
Wir brauchen Avira.
Gibt es das noch für Windows XP?
Das gibt es bestimmt nicht, oder?
Oh, die haben es eingestellt.
Free Anti-Virus für Windows, den will ich haben.
Avira.de, was auch immer.
Ich will, ich will Avira.
Okay, geht nicht mehr.
7zip, klar.
DuckDuckGo.
7zip.
Kennst du das Windows XP Destruction Video?
Nee.
7zip, da haben wir es.
Ja, welche denn?
Ob die noch geht unter XP?
Am Moment 64-bit?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, 32-bit.
Das ist ja aus Zeiten, da war mit 64-bit noch nicht so viel.
Und jetzt hat das installiert?
Excellent.
Guck mal, wie einfach das ging.
Guck mal, wie einfach das ging damals.
Ohne irgendwelchen komischen 30 Milliarden Sachen einfach zack zack installiert, fertig.
Oh, WinRAR.
Nee, Leute, wisst ihr, was ich damals immer hatte?
WinRAR, ich hatte damals WinAce.
Kennt das noch jemand?
WinAce?
So sah das aus.
Die coolen Leute, also die Noobs hatten WinRAR, ich hatte WinAce.
Das ist ein Parkprogramm.
Und ich muss gestehen, wisst ihr, warum ich WinAce hatte?
Weil zur damaligen Zeit ziemlich viele Seiten, auf denen Sicherheitskopien zum Runterladen bereit standen, hatten dieses WinAce-Format.
Okay, die Updates, guck mal, die Updates gehen.
Guck mal hier.
Die Updates funktionieren immer noch.
Ein Windows XP Update ist am Start.
Install.
Leute, ich habe 20 Jahre keine Windows Updates mehr, keine Windows XP Updates mehr installiert.
Und es funktioniert noch.
Hyper-Poggers.
Und übrigens, Outlook Express, dieses E-Mail-Programm, das ist nach wie vor besser von den Features her als das Windows 10-Mail-Programm.
Das Windows 10-Mail-Programm ist absoluter Bullshit.
Aber natürlich total unsicher und unterbrochen.
Das ist nichts Neues mehr.
Was haben wir hier, Windows Media Player?
Next, Next, Next, Finish.
Genau, da hatte man noch diese abgetreten, diese abgetreten Skins hat man dann noch irgendwo drin.
Und Menübedienung, wo man keine Ahnung mehr hatte, wie man überhaupt den Kram hier bedient.
Skinchooser.
Und Skinchooser.
Corporate Reaver.
More Skins.
Oh, es gibt keinen Movie Maker mehr.
Das macht mich jetzt aber traurig.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich einen Movie Maker ausprobieren.
Doch, da ist er.
Porras, der Movie Maker.
Machen wir gleich, ich muss erstmal gucken, dass der Sound geht.
Warum geht denn der Sound nicht?
Ok, YouTube.
Ich starte mal wieder, warum geht der Sound nicht?
Ok, eben ging es aber noch besser.
Ah.
Also eben lief das Video noch besser.
Ah, jetzt geht es, ok.
Also hieran kann es nicht liegen.
Ah, kann es sein, dass der Windows Mixer die vor allem einfach leise gemacht hat?
Da ist der Sound.
Winamp Download XP.
Winamp, oh, full, full.
Nicht einfach irgendwas, der richtig, der richtig echte legit.
Der echte Winamper.
Was?
Chip, please.
Come on, bruh.
PC-Welt.
Genau, dann laden wir jetzt von PC-Welt runter.
Ist das das erste Mal, dass die Menschen hochschießen?
Ja, ja.
Direkt zum Download, PC-Welt.
Ok, Download.
Oh, da ist Windows XP gar nicht mehr dabei.
Aber Vista, wenn Vista dabei ist, geht XP auch.
Winamp.
Beta.
Sogar die Beta, Leute.
Und Heise hat es auch am Start.
Da nehmen wir, nee, wir nehmen das von Heise, Heise, besser.
Ja, GIF Heise.
Ach, Moment.
Ist das Beta?
Kann das sein, dass das gar nicht das alte, das alte Winamp, das alte Winamp ist, so wie man sich das vorstellt?
I agree, next.
What the fuck?
Ich will die File Extensions ausmachen.
Ah, komm.
Firewall, stimmt, diese komische Windows Firewall war ja auch am Start.
Ah, bei der Installation Light auswählen, ah, zu spät.
Ah, hier, Classic.
Excellent.
Nee, nee, du sollst dich mit nichts verknüpfen, geh mal fort.
Ah.
Da ist es ja, da ist es ja.
Oh, der MSN Messenger, den gab es ja auch noch damals.
Irgendwie mochte ich den Style von Windows XP, ganz, ganz ehrlich, also mir gefällt Windows XP von der Optik.
Das ist irgendwie so, so fröhlich und leicht und, und alles, das, das sieht nicht so, nicht so Business Enterprise, ja, ich weiß, dass es noch running ist, nicht so Business Enterprise mäßig aus.
Klick hier to sign in.
Was ist, wenn ich keinen Account habe?
.NET Passport.
Hallo?
Geht nicht mehr, ist kaputt.
.NET Passport kann ich nicht kriegen.
Das ist aus der Zeit, ähm, wo Microsoft alles irgendwie dummerweise.NET genannt hat.
Alles ist irgendwie.NET richtig hängen geblieben im Nachhinein.
So, und was, was der, was richtig nice war, ähm, in Windows XP, weiß ich nicht, ob ihr das noch nennt, Style XP ist das glaube ich oder Stylish XP?
War das Style XP?
Ja.
Das da.
Das meine ich.
Da gab es so richtig.
Okay, der Browser kackt, kackt gerade ab.
Oder war das nicht Style, Style, Windows XP, da konntest du richtig nice abgedrehte Sachen machen.
Stimmt, es waren ja sogar auch ganz brauchbare mit dabei, ne?
Classic?
Ja, so wie man es kennt.
Oh, more themes online, da hab ich so meine Zweifel, dass die noch online sind.
Da hab ich so meine Zweifel, dass die noch online sind.
Oh, sorry.
Ja, wow.
Big, big, big brain buttons.
Jetzt wird's wieder normal.
Visual Style Windows XP.
Wie hieß denn der Kram?
Tune Up Utilities.
Oh ja, Tune Up Utilities, den Kram braucht man natürlich auch, ganze Bullshit da.
Oder war das das hier?
War das das hier?
Ah, VG Perform.
Oh, jetzt installieren wir aber richtigen Crap.
Style XP, ne?
Jaja, so hieß das.
Style XP Download, ziemlich sicher.
Chip, wir downloaden das einfach von Chip.
Chip.
Seems so alte SpaceX, ja, später, noch passiert ja nix.
Ich will nicht den Chip Installer.
Chip, please.
Lass mich einfach ne normal, oder heißt das Ding einfach nur Chip Installer.
Wie krieg ich das ohne diesen köstlichen Chip Installer?
Ach hier, manuelle Installation.
Oh, das haben sie aber auch heftig versteckt, oder?
Die wollen unbedingt diesen komischen Chip Installer unter die Leute bringen.
Jebaited.
Female.
What?
Hallo?
Open.
Styler, Feeb, ich hab Angst Leute.
Ich hab Angst das auszuführen, ey.
Da ist bestimmt ein Porn Installer drin, oder so.
Was?
Koff-Trop?
Was zum Teufel ist...
Ja, yes.
Yes.
Was?
Was auch immer.
Hä?
Warum geht das nicht?
Ist meine Windows XP Version zu neu oder was?
Aber das ist das hier doch.
Corona.
Corona Violet.
Was ist mit denen los?
Ich kann das nicht installieren, das ist ja doof.
Meine Windows Version ist zu neu.
Und wisst ihr was ich auch cool fand?
Man konnte damals total easy einfach Programme löschen.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Es gab mal Zeit, da konnte man einfach unter Windows Programme löschen oder generell irgendwas finden noch.
Und wie der Eax gesagt hat, man hat sogar für das Betriebssystem noch Aim gebraucht.
Was war das andere, was wir da runter...
Ah, Foggy, das installiere ich mir nicht.
Das ist Crapware hoch 10 mit Sicherheit.
Schade, dass Styling's Pain immer funktioniert.
Doof.
Ah, löschen was, löschen was.
Delete.
So, was hatten wir denn sonst noch schönes?
Tour, jetzt können wir uns endlich mal die Tour angucken.
Ist das Cortana?
Cortana, Vorgänger.
Ich hab...
Ich hab mir das nie angeguckt.
Es klingt wirklich ein bisschen wie Cortana.
So, endlich ist der Windows Movie Maker am Start.
Exzellent.
Hatte man nicht noch so ein paar Tests?
Sample Pictures gab's, genau.
So, gab's nicht auch Sample Movies oder sowas?
Oh nee, da ist nix drin.
Was wir machen können, ist...
So, was installieren wir noch mal?
Was können wir noch mal ausprobieren?
Was waren für die damalige Zeit...
Steam.
Steam wird, glaub ich, auch nicht mehr unterstützt.
Steam geht, glaub ich, auch noch mehr.
CS 1.6, ich hab wieder Half-Life.
Ich hab wieder Half-Life, noch läuft es hier richtig.
Gab's nicht immer das Sample Video von dem Pferd, das an der Küste gerannt ist?
Sagt mir jetzt nix.
Portal 2, top aktuelle Werbung.
Der Sach bestimmt wird nicht mehr unterstützt.
Ich lock mich hier aber garantiert nicht in Steam ein.
Ich lock mich hier garantiert nicht in Steam ein.
Ah, jebaited.
Richtig krass.
Jebaited.
Richtig jebaited.
Aber wenigstens sollten jetzt diese blöden Browser Games hier ordentlich funktionieren.
Nickname.
KacW.
Play.
Oh, es laggt schon.
Oh, fuck, Alter.
Wonka.
Oh, 5 FPS.
Wir müssen das kleiner machen, dann geht's bestimmt besser.
Oh, fuck.
Das ist RIP.
Das ist richtig RIP.
Okay, probieren wir was anderes aus.
Last Chrome Version XP.
Was ist die letzte Chrome Version?
Okay, dann installieren wir mal Chrome 49.
Ja, ich würde es gerne downloaden.
Einmal ohne Chip Installer, please.
Geht das auch ohne Chip Installer?
Ich will aber nicht den Chip Installer.
Das ist wieder der KacChip Installer.
Nee.
Nee, ist nicht.
Perfekt.
Damals war es so, gerade bei den bisschen älteren Versionen,
viele Sachen liefen damals performancemäßig, was so Gaming und schnelle Zeichensachen anbelangt,
liefen besser auf Chrome.
Discord.
Unknown Installer Error, perfekt.
Aber Discord im Browser könnte vielleicht sogar funktionieren.
Geht.
I'm not a robot.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das war's, oder?
Dann mach hin.
Hier haben wir noch eins.
Was?
Ich hab zu oft auf Verify geklickt.
Da, da, da, da.
Hallo, da, Verify.
Und jetzt?
Ah, ich bin kein Robot.
Excellent.
Und Discord.
Connecting.
Da ist er.
Discord ist am Start.
Aber es geht nicht.
Es geht so halb.
Wobei, wir haben ja hier nichts drinne.
Okay.
Add Server.
Join Server.
End.
Ausrufezeichen.
Discord.
Copy Link Address.
Join.
Hä?
Okay, kann das sein, dass eine Discord-Link nicht funktioniert?
Oder doch?
Nee, geht.
Alles gut.
Invite...
Sebaro, bist du am Start?
Wir brauchen einen neuen Invite-Link.
Nein.
Something out of the ordinary is going on.
Okay.
Okay, aber Discord würde theoretisch funktionieren.
Leute, geht bei euch der Discord-Link?
Es könnte einfach sein, dass das bei euch geht.
Ja, aber auch wenn ihr noch nicht eingeladen seid.
Okay.
Ja, dann... Hä?
Es war einfach broken, kann das sein?
Okay.
Top.
Discord geht.
Discord ruckelt wie Sau, aber Discord geht.
Ich mein, Windows XP, ein uralt Firefox und Discord geht.
Orgas, sehr nice.
Sehr schön.
Guck mal, ob der geht.
Kranger.
Hä?
Loading?
Chrome last version XP.
Ich brauch unbedingt eine Windows XP Version von Chrome.
Der Kram lief damals einfach viel schneller in Chrome.
Ja, Chrome XP 4932 Download.
File Puma, klingt äußerst vielversprechend.
File Puma.
Ach, kommt mal direkt von Google.
Chrome Standalone Enterprise, alles klar, das wollte ich schon immer mal installieren.
Chrome Standalone Enterprise, alles klar.
Kein Problem.
Okay, das ist total kaputt, das ligt nicht richtig.
Aber vielleicht können wir Chrome Enterprise, weil es ist Enterprise und dann muss das besser funktionieren.
Weil Enterprise Software ja bekannt dafür ist, dass sie so gut funktioniert.
Ich hab echt so viele Erinnerungen an das ganze Ding hier.
Was?
Oh, leck mich, was ist das?
Last version Chrome XP.
Was ist das hier?
Ja, File Puma.
Was zum Geier ist File Puma?
Sieht äußerst vertrauenserweckend aus, File Puma.
Erstmal nebenbei irgendwelche komischen...
File Puma.
Virus total scan, genau, machen wir jetzt.
Hat er jetzt runtergeladen?
Virus total.
Pinball.
Ist das standartmäßig überhaupt dabei?
Ah, excellent, 3D Pinball.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich mir die Dinge überhaupt bedient hat hier unten.
Wie geht das?
Welcher Knopf war das nochmal?
Bisschen laut, oder?
Punkt oder Komma, echt?
Hier, da hat man gewackelt, da hat man gewackelt.
Weil File-Tasten gehen nicht.
Okay, Options, Player Controls.
Z und X?
Was ist, da kommt doch keiner drauf.
Z und X, ach, X und Y, nee.
Jetzt geht's wieder nicht mehr.
Ach, leck mich, ist voll kaputt.
Eigentlich hab ich deutsche Tastatur, ne?
Okay, scannen wir jetzt mal bei Virus total, was wir da runtergeladen haben.
Scannen wir das mal von File Puma.
Ja.
File published by Google, das klingt schon mal ganz gut.
Ist das schon fertig?
Okay, ich glaube, ich glaube, das können wir installieren.
It's a safe.
Poki V.
Es ist safe.
Guck mal da.
Es ist ein Chrome.
Es ist ein echter, ein richtig echter Chrome.
Your connection is not private, who cares?
Ein richtig echter Chrome.
Ich weiß, dass meine Connection not private ist.
Da laufen die, da laufen die Sachen besser drin im Chrome.
Und Gott, Sprache zu einem Chrome, genau.
Mal gucken, ob das besser läuft.
Okay, läuft gar nicht, kannste komplett vergessen.
Was sagt denn der Task Manager?
Geht, macht nichts, lädt nicht.
Lull.
Guckt mal hier, Leute, seht ihr das?
Wie viel flüssiger das läuft, seht ihr das?
Ich sag euch, die Sachen, zur damaligen Zeit war Chrome, was 3D-Sachen angeht und so, richtig, also viel, viel besser.
Es hat sogar kaum Lacks, wenn du hier im Fullspeed rumdüst.
Stimmt er in der Uhrzeit, ja, jaja.
Sehr gut, excellent.
Oh meine, ich bin wieder klein, Leute, ich bin wieder klein.
Ja, so sah der Chrome damals aus.
Die letzte Chrome-Version, die es für Windows XP gegeben hat.
YouTube.
Mal gucken, was aktueller ist.
Chrome oder Firefox, was YouTube-Videos angeht?
Firefox.
Im Chrome ist es komplett kaputt, im Chrome geht es nicht.
Im Firefox geht es noch.
Cool, sehr schön.
Mir fällt es leider nicht ein, was man in Windows XP noch großzeitig machen könnte, aber ich muss echt nochmal sagen,
also irgendwie habe ich sehr viele schöne Erinnerungen an Windows XP, nicht so sehr an Windows XP selber, sondern auf dem, was man auf Windows XP gemacht hat.
Gibt es eigentlich noch, gibt es noch eine Windows XP-Version von Avira?
Oldversion.com.
Excellent, das müssen wir uns jetzt installieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für eine kacke Software ist.
Wir machen mal Virus total.
Machen wir mal wieder auf.
Erstmal wieder Virus-Check machen.
Schau mal, ob es einen Pfeil-Puma gibt.
Wir haben wieder was gelernt, Pfeil-Puma.
Klingt so vertrauenserweckend, findet ihr nicht auch?
Pfeil-Puma.
Ahi, ahi.
Toolbar, Toolbar könnte sogar tatsächlich der Antivirus selbst sein.
SirEddy, temple, drei Monate, dankeschön, excellent subscription, big brain.
Aber die Wicht, Ask.com Toolbar, die haben sie damals beworben, wie verrückt.
Nee, nicht also, Ask.com Toolbar.
Oh, Bundle Toolbar, ich weiß, dass ein Toolbar drinnen ist.
Google Toolbar, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Microsoft Internet Explorer 6, da können wir mit dienen, das ist kein Problem.
Wenn die wollen, ja wie jetzt?
Die Google Toolbar geht nicht im Firefox, aber Internet Explorer, für die sie geht, kann ich sie nicht aufmachen.
Das ist ja excellent.
Ah, okay, einfach HTTPS weg machen.
Google Toolbar, gibs mir, Alter, gib mir die Google.
Okay, die gibt es nicht mehr, die gibt sie, ist weg, Google Toolbar.
Hast du mal Windows in dem EME benutzt, klar.
Ah, was Toolbar, die habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Ah, was Toolbar mit Shopping, mit Shopping-Spion, oh, die brauchen wir natürlich.
Puffra Exploit.
Also ich würde ja sagen, das ist falscher Alarm, weil die halt auf was anschlagen, was in diesem Virenscanner drin ist, aber weiß was, scheiß drauf.
Ah, was Toolbar mit dem Shopping-Spion, was ein Dummfug, ey.
Gibt es denn für Firefox, was war das, Firefox 52?
Firefox 52, gibt es da U-Block Origin für?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber Adblock gibt es.
Ne, ne, Mozilla Mods.
Ja, die erste.com Toolbar haben wir ja gerade schon angeguckt.
Okay, mindestens 55, aber die Adblock Plus gab es doch da immer, oder?
Ah, hier, zack.
Adblock Plus, die sind ja dann irgendwie in Verruf geraten.
Die sind ja dann irgendwie in Verruf geraten, weiß auch nicht so genau warum.
Weil sie glaube ich Werbung verkauft haben, also sprich werbefreie Sachen verkauft haben.
Aber zumindest haben wir jetzt schon mal auf YouTube keine Werbung mehr.
Und wir können uns angucken, wie unge-reacted, nein, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Und keine Werbung.
Excellent, nice.
Das heißt wir können uns jetzt, was richtig Meta wäre jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt einfach den Space Extreme im Firefox unter Windows XP an.
Was?
Moment.
Warum?
Eben ging es doch noch.
Jetzt ist der Browser RIP.
Kann das sein, dass Livestreams andere Formate haben als Videos?
Hä?
Ah, das liegt an Adblock.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich an Adblock.
Ah ja.
Ok, bei meinen Videos lag es an Adblock hier nicht.
Ok, das geht nicht.
Aber soll ich noch was sagen, es fühlt sich, ok jetzt lag es, aber das fühlt sich unglaublich schnell in der, das hier ohne Scheiß, das fühlt sich mega schnell in der VM an im Vergleich zu Windows 10.
Und wisst ihr was, die Windows Suche hat glaube ich auch.
Fällt mir gerade wieder ein, die komischen Hundkapster ja.
Ist ja eins schlimmer als das andere.
Also man muss ja sagen, die Suche unter Windows XP, die hat halt richtig oldschool einfach die Platte durchsucht, ohne Index oder sonst wie, aber sie hat meistens funktioniert.
Die Büroklammer, ja die Büroklammer gab es ja in Windows in Office.
Was war denn, was für ein Office war denn aktuell zu Windows XP Zeiten so 2000, Office 2000, Office 2005 oder so?
Gibt es da noch eine Demo-Version von?
Office 2003, genau.
Archief.org
Hier, excellent.
Oh Leute, ihr habt nichts gesehen, ihr habt nichts gesehen.
Nix.
Subscribers.
Oh die Seite leckt jetzt gerade.
Was macht denn Google da im Hintergrund?
Demo, Demo.
Gab es da eine Demo von?
Ne.
Na ja.
Key League.
Die originale Wiese, hier guck mal an.
Ich habe aber hier auch die Wiese, nur dass meine Wiese höher aufgelöst ist als die original Windows XP Wiese.
Also das ist die original Windows XP Wiese nur eine höhere Auflösung.
Was hatten die eigentlich nochmal hier für einen Kram dabei?
Desktop, genau Blizz ist das Streaming Screen.
Center, ja genau das war nämlich ziemlich klein.
Was hatten die dann noch dabei?
Windows XP.
Das ist der gleiche Crap den es dann auch unter, ja das ist der gleiche Müll den es auch schon in der Windows 98 gegeben hat.
Richtiger, richtiger Shit.
Wer hatte ihn, Leute ernsthaft wer ist so alt dass er zu der Zeit noch aktiv war und hatte nicht mindestens einmal diesen Pipe Bildschirm Schoner eingestellt?
Gibt es nicht oder?
Jeder, jeder hat diesen Pipe Bildschirm Schoner mal.
Der ist doch noch krass, naja.
Labyrinth ist eklig, Labyrinth ist ich weiß gar nicht ob das überhaupt noch dabei ist.
Das Labyrinth in, oh high quality.
Das Labyrinth war in der 98 dabei, aber hier ist er nicht mehr dabei.
Power.
Was die hatten, die hatten Support für eine USB.
Silver, das hatte ich auch mal eine Weile kann ich mich noch dran erinnern nicht Oliw, Silver, Silver hatte ich auch mal eine Weile kann ich mich noch tunkelt dran erinnern genau.
Da kann ich mir voll stylisch vor, dass ich das immer auf Silver hatte.
Achja, das war schon schön.
Das hatte was, aber nicht XP an sich, sondern einfach was man auf XP gemacht hat damals.
Die Optik gefällt mir immer noch ziemlich gut.
Das hat irgendwie so ein bisschen was eigenes.
Es hat irgendwie so eine gewisse eigene Identität im Vergleich zu dem von Windows 10.
Aber ich erinnere mich hauptsächlich an das was ich da drauf gemacht habe.
Was hatte ich denn für ein Login Bild?
Den da, den hatte ich glaube ich immer.
Okay, wie weit sind die eigentlich mit Space? Oh, sie sitzen drinnen.
Ja gut, das dauert jetzt noch ewig.
Wer kennt noch das WinXP Zoom Theme? Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Was war das?
Ach, Zoom, das war der Microsoft Audio Player, oder?
Wann ist geplanter Start? Ich glaube 21.22 Uhr.
Also ich weiß gar nicht ob ich so lange on bleiben soll.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich zum Raketenstart on kommen.
Aber ich hatte auch geplant, dass ich jetzt wieder off gehe.
Warum ist da immer noch da?
Und ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das jetzt machen soll am besten.
Wie sie sich freuen alle.
Nee, bleib on. Dann musst du mir jetzt aber auch sagen was ich in der Zeit machen soll.
Als erstes muss ich jetzt erstmal was essen.
Also ich hab Hunger.
Die sitzen nicht ernsthaft noch zwei Stunden.
Locker, klar, die sitzen wahrscheinlich sogar schon ein bisschen länger.
Und wenn du dir anguckst wie lange die teilweise im Cockpit früher gesessen haben.
Also früher halt 1970 rum.
Die haben da teilweise 16 Stunden oder irgendwie so rumgehockt.
Zu Testzwecken.
Das ging schon.
Barbecue Pit Boys. Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Hat der gerade gesagt ein Meatball?
Wir gucken jetzt Barbecue Pit Boys auf YouTube.
Firefox 52 Windows XP.
Da müssen wir aber auch Videos angucken von während ich esse.
Videos angucken von 2000 oldest.
13 Jahre kommt hin oder?
Von wann waren die Windows XP aktuell?
Windows XP Release Date 2001.
Und der Nachfolger kam dann wann?
Das hat kein Mensch benutzt.
Was ist da? 2006.
Extended Support Management.
Also bis 2009. 2009.
Weil das sind jetzt 13 Jahre, das ist 2007.
Na ja doch, das passt.
Grill T-Bone Steak. Exzellent.
Exzellent, okay, das gucken wir jetzt.
Moment, ist das noch? What the fuck?
Ist das noch 4 zu 3?
Sehe ich das richtig, dass die Videos damals noch in 4 zu 3 waren?
Okay.
16 zu 9 sollte es schon sein.
Easy Cheeseburger.
Alter, es ist 4 zu 3.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken, Leute.
4 zu 3 halte ich nicht aus.
4 zu 3 geht nicht. Nee, das ist...
Aber vor 10 Jahren, Leute, 10 Jahre ist doch nichts.
Vor 10 Jahren habe ich...
Da habe ich 60 FPS gecaptured schon.
Von der Xbox. 16 zu 9, 720p, 60 FPS.
Dann gucken wir doch hier.
Bacon Baked Potato Dogs.
Ich freeze mal kurz hier meine Windows XP VM.
Und...
Ist das jetzt abgeschissen? Nee.
So, wir schreiben mal einen Titel.
Ich brauche mal noch einen Streamtitel.
Space... Genau.
Da war der Name noch Programm. Ja, 60 FPS war damals richtig exquisite.
High Quality.
Technik, Zeug und danach...
Zeug und danach...
SpaceX Launchgucken.
Wir schreiben nicht Launch.
Für die Noobs schreiben wir Raketenstart.
SpaceX eigentlich SpaceX groß und X dann...
Das verstehen dann sogar die Boomer. Das ist mein Ziel.
Weil ich bin ja selbst nicht ganz einer, aber ich bin dazwischen.
Ich bin so 1984 geboren. Das ist quasi ein Zoomer.
Quasi so einer dazwischen.
Ich bin die erste Generation, die so wirklich komplett mit dem Computerkram aufgewachsen ist.
Davor, die haben da teilweise überhaupt keinen Bezug.
Und danach sind die Leute teilweise so doof, dass sie...
Außer wenn es ihnen nicht gerade irgendwas auf dem Smartphone sagt, das nicht checken.
Ah, exzellent. Schön Kokona-Programm.
Moment, den Typ da hinten hab ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Ist das nicht der aus Jurassic Park?
Das sieht jetzt viel älter aus, aber das ist doch der Typ aus Jurassic.
Jurassic Park Actors.
Der da!
Der tut, der ist das. Guck mal.
Das ist der.
Der hat sogar ne Brille auf, die so ähnlich aussieht.
Das ist der Jurassic Park Typ.
Moment, der übersteuert ein bisschen.
Chopped.
Ah, yes.
Das ist nicht 4 zu 3.
Soll ich erstmal kurz meinen Pulsen jetzt nehmen, Beiner?
What?
Schneidet er grad mit dem Teppichmesser seine Würstchen?
Moment.
Die sind geil. Die sind so geil.
Mein favorite dog ist eindeutig der Franker Z.
Das ist ein Trollvideo, oder?
Das ist der Troll, das ist keine Absicht.
Normalerweise machen sie die Sachen immer relativ sinnvoll.
Hab ich.
Ey, das könnte fast sogar den Akkuschrauber sein, den ich auch hab.
Warte mal, ich hab hier einen.
Der hat meinen Akkuschrauber. Perfekt.
Das heißt, das nächste Mal weiß ich ja, wie ich Kartoffeln zubereite.
Das ist er.
Der hat aber die Variante mit Schlagfunktion noch.
Das ist er aber.
Ja, der hat noch mit Schlagfunktion hier.
Der hat quasi den hier.
PSR Schlag.
Der hat den hier, guckt.
Das ist der Original. Ihr seht ja sogar oben die Icons.
Moment, warum gucken wir eigentlich auf 4K? Egal, YOLO.
Warum macht der da eigentlich Löcher rein?
SpaceX ist noch nicht soweit.
Die feiern sich gerade noch Kokona-Style.
Ja, mal gucken, ob ich es bis dahin schaffe.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall auch ein bisschen Sachen, die wir im Stream machen können bis dahin.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gewechselt.
Die Würste sehen aber echt gut aus.
Oder Leute, sagt mal, die Würstchen sehen echt gut aus.
Hast du schon mal FPGAs programmiert? Nee?
Alter, wie viel Butter ist das? Ja gut, du musst ja zumindest die Chance haben, dass du einen Herzinfarkt kriegst danach.
W insanlar spätst.
We'll turn those taters and bake them up.
And we got a temperature of the grill somewhere about 350, maybe a little higher.
Ich hab grad kurz so zu meinem Essen runtergekocht.
Ist das die geschmolzene Butter hier?
WTF?
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja ne Packung Butter, oder?
Haha!
Okay, allright, the taters have been baked.
Wow!
Check a look at that, right?
Oh, there's some good eating right there.
That's all you need, right?
But no, you gotta check this out.
Now we'll add some sliced cheese.
We got some cheddar going in.
Use your favorite sliced cheese.
You gotta make it your own, right?
This is all pit master privilege.
Now we'll take one of those butter bath dogs.
Place it on.
Das... warum ist das so viel?
Das... die brauchen doch die viele Butter gar nicht.
Das... die... die brauchen doch die viele Butter gar nicht.
Das schmeckt doch... das schmeckt doch schon super, wenn das einfach vom Grill kommt.
Stop there.
That's good enough.
Add some chopped onion.
Now you can set these up the way you want.
Of course, that's pit master privilege.
But this is a good way to do it.
Now we're gonna take some of that bacon.
Sprinkle it on.
Throw in a pickle.
And then we're gonna take some of that...
Nein, please!
Oh nein, please!
Alright? Just got a little of that dog.
Please!
That dog flavor in there and just spoon it on.
Es reicht doch nicht. Es reicht doch nicht.
Remember, this is your wedding.
Do it the way you want.
Ohhhh.
Man.
Place a backgrond grill indirect.
So we can melt down the cheese.
And this is what you got.
Whoa. Take a look at that.
Now this is the part...
We're gonna eat it in front of you.
You know?
Put on your favorite condiments.
We got some mustard and chup.
And what condiments you use
is totally up to you.
So here the pit master...
Mit dem Bart, Alter.
Manchmal ist Bart wirklich...
...ist einem im Weg, ja.
Also ich merke das manchmal. Ich hab ja auch ein bisschen Bart.
Wenn ich merke, dass ich mir mehr als sonst
den Mund abputzen muss, weil irgendwo in irgendwer
schon irgendwas hängen bleibt, weiß ich, okay.
Spätestens jetzt ist es Zeit, mal wieder ordentlich zu rasieren.
Aber ich glaube, es schmeckt gut.
Es ist zwar ungesund
as fuck gewesen, ja.
Peppered Pork Bacon Burger.
Das haben wir schon geguckt, glaube ich.
Was ist das?
Haben wir das auch schon geguckt?
Excellent.
Die haben immer so Riesenzwiebeln.
Die Zwiebel vom Lidl
ist ungefähr so.
Und die haben so mega mutierte,
genmanipulierte Riesenzwiebel.
Ah, die eist die Machete wieder.
Ich hab mir schon Gedanken gemacht, die Machete ist kaputt.
Wobei, das ist ein Altersvideo, vielleicht ist sie kaputt.
Das ist Fenstreiniger.
Aber das ist Grillreiniger.
Aber das ist Fenstreiniger.
Das ist nicht eigentlich eine schlechte Idee,
das Hackfleisch in die Zwiebeln zu schmeißen.
Das ist nicht eigentlich eine schlechte Idee, das Hackfleisch in die Zwiebeln zu schmeißen.
Weil dann brät es doch gar nicht
richtig schön an, oder?
Wäre es nicht sinnvoller,
erstmal das Hackfleisch reinzuschmeißen
und zumindest zu gucken, dass es schön braun ist,
außenrum.
Dann kann man ja die Zwiebel
dabei schmeißen, danach wird es ja nicht mehr...
Dann kann man ja die Zwiebel dabei schmeißen, danach wird es ja nicht mehr...
Oder vielleicht bin ich einfach nur nicht...
Jetzt habe ich nicht genug brain dafür, kann auch sein.
Ich glaube, das ist das, wieso ihr es hier aufgeteilt habt.
Aber ihr müsst diese Rezeptur ausprobieren.
Es ist gut.
Weil wir hier am Kettel sind,
haben wir nicht viel Raum.
Wir drehen nur den schwarzen,
oder den verpassten,
um etwas einfach zu kochen.
Herr, haben Sie Gnade.
Ihr könnt nicht glauben, wie gut es riecht.
Sagt mal, das Voice-Over machen die doch zu 90% auch aus irgendeinem Soundboard, oder?
Das Voice-Over besteht zu 90% auf...
It smells good.
Und im Prinzip ist das jedes Video alles ab und zu das gleiche.
Hast du Tipps oder Lektüre, mit denen man sich gut an Donate ran tasten kann?
Ja, ich esse jetzt noch mal ein halbes Brot, fertig, dann zeige ich dir was.
Indirect. Boah, ist das ein riesen Haufen, Alter.
Jetzt müssen wir sie ausprobieren. Und hier geben wir ein paar Kornstärze, um den Pop-Pie aufzuwenden.
Und hier ein paar Zwiebeln, mit einem gelben Zwiebeln.
Willst du einen braunen Zwiebeln oder irgendeinen, den du möchtest?
Geh direkt los.
Ich habe die Barchete mit für alles genommen.
Jetzt machen wir den Brot in die Bratwurst, in die wir schon ein paar Zwiebeln gelegt haben.
Und wir werden sie sehr schön aussehen und diese Sausages in die Bratwurst leeren.
Ich denke, du weißt, wo wir mit dem herkommen, oder?
Jetzt noch ein paar von deiner Bratwurst. Oh Mann.
Jetzt noch ein paar gebollene Zwiebeln. Du willst keine rohen Zwiebeln in die Bratwurst, du brauchst sie zu kochen.
Und jetzt noch ein paar Zwiebeln.
Nimm deine Lieblingszwiebeln.
Jetzt noch die restlichen Zwiebeln.
Ich brauche dir wirklich keine Zwiebeln mehr zeigen, denn ich denke, du hast sie schon.
Aber wieso nicht?
Ja, Fleischlasagne, sowas in der... Ja, das ist wirklich...
Das ist echt so eine Art Fleischlasagne.
Ja, dass es schön braun ist.
Leute, ich habe ein Problem.
Ich habe jetzt alles fertig gegessen, also ich habe ein Brötchen gegessen und ein Stück Brot zusammengeklappt.
Und irgendwie habe ich noch Hunger heute.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich zu viele Kokona-Videos geguckt habe.
Fahr zu McDonalds, ja, ist klar.
Ich werde sie nehmen bei und lasse sie streamen, oder wie?
Okay, farbermäßig sieht schon mal echt gut aus.
Die Machete ist wieder da.
Das liegt da schon eine Weile, wenn das rauskommt, ist das brutal heiß.
Die Sounds immer...
Der macht 100% des Videos sind Soundboards.
Es wäre viel besser, wenn sie das Essen mal zeigen würden.
Anstatt dass wir sehen, wie... Ah, hier, okay.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wahrscheinlich schmeckt es ganz gut, aber optisch wahnsinnig gut aussehen tut es nicht.
Aber die haben kein Händchen für ihr Essen gut zu präsentieren.
Das sieht bei all diesen Videos nicht gut aus.
Am Ende...
Und, wie sieht es aus?
Gibt es noch einen Launch Timer?
Ach genau, Wetter-Update.
Und wie sieht es denn aus?
Okay, nee, gibt es nix.
Die labern, die labern immer noch.
Wo startet die Rakete?
Keine Ahnung.
Florida.
Okay, genau.
Irgendjemand hat doch gerade gefragt, ob ich Lektüre zu.NET habe.
Ist derjenige noch da, also lohnt sich das noch zu beantworten?
Ah, du, okay, also.
Das beste Buch, was du kostenlos kriegen kannst, ist das hier.
Das hier.
Also wenn du ein kostenloses Buch suchst, von Anfang bis Ende ist das gut.
Allerdings, wohlgemerkt, das ist ja ein Buch, was ursprünglich mal von 2010 oder 2008 oder so ist.
Oder 2005, ich glaube sogar 2005 oder so.
Da sind viele Sachen drin, die es heute zwar noch gibt, aber die nicht so wichtig sind.
Aber deswegen würde ich sagen, was man in diesem Buch machen kann, ist alles inklusive 16.
1 bis 16, da hast du einen echt guten Überblick schon über so die.NET Basics und kannst auch loslegen.
Danach kommt WPF, was dich nicht interessieren muss und Datenbankzeug, was sich auch mal erst nicht interessieren muss.
Und Gedöns.
Also 1 bis 16 lohnt sich auf jeden Fall zu machen.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass manche Sachen relativ überholt sind.
Also XML und Binary Serialization muss man sich nicht unbedingt angucken.
Aber der Rest ist immer noch aktuell.
Das hier ist auch nicht mehr so aktuell.
Heute machen wir das alles über irgendwelche Tasks.
Aber das Buch kann ich dir empfehlen.
Guck einfach mal, wie gesagt, 1 bis 16 ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, sich anzugucken.
Und dann natürlich, was auch immer super ist, wenn du dir die Sachen von Microsoft selbst anguckst.
Hier haben wir jede Menge Webcasts zu aktuellen Sachen.
Letztens gab es auch erst ein Video zu neuen C-Sharp.
Neun Features.
Die Suche ist scheiße.
Du kannst auch bei denen auf den YouTube-Channels gucken.
Das ist auch gut.
Aber wenn du einfach nur eine gute Einführung suchst, dann macht das Buch 1 bis 16 und gut ist.
Excellent.
Wir gucken mal kurz, was wir bei Stream-Ideen noch stehen haben.
Weil es ist ja immerhin noch fast über eineinhalb Stunden, bis die Raketen-Startstells machen.
Sende mal den Link vom Buch.
Such einfach bei Google...
Ach komm, ich schick's dir.
Okay, er hat's schon.
Kannst einfach bei Google suchen.
Galileo, OpenPress, C-Sharp, Buch.
So, was haben wir bei Stream-Ideen denn noch?
Schön ist drin.
Also, ReactOS haben wir heute gemacht.
Mac OS VM kann ich nicht machen.
Würde sich zeitmäßig eigentlich richtig gut anbieten, dass ich die Mac OS VM heute mal ausprobiere.
Ich glaube, ich kann keinen VirtualBox installieren.
Ohne, dass ich neu starten muss.
WinRAR-Review anschauen.
What the fuck?
Okay, machen wir.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Wir grillen jetzt was und machen dabei.
It's real easy to do.
Pitmaster privilege.
Was ist das?
Oh nein.
Bing. Bing.
Gibt es wirklich jemanden, der mal WinRAR...
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, Cronk hat mal WinRAR gekauft.
Aber, gibt es...
Ja, doch, doch.
Eigentlich ist die Frage, Max...
Also, ich kann mir die Frage selbst beantworten.
Weil wir auf der Arbeit haben WinRAR gekauft.
Wir haben WinRAR vorinstalliert auf unseren Windows-Desktops, die von der Arbeit zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Und da ist WinRAR drauf.
Also, ich habe Linux auf der Arbeit, mich betrifft das nicht so.
Aber bei uns auf der Arbeit ist WinRAR drauf.
Die haben das garantiert gekauft.
Und ich war eben jetzt die Win.RAR GmbHs von RAR Labs.
Oh.
Unglaublich.
Oh, das funktioniert?
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, es läuft total ins Leere.
rarkey.rar
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, mein E-Mail-Programm hätte im Leben die E-Mail nicht angezeigt, wenn ich eine Datei bekomme mit rarkey.rar.
Easy!
Poggers Review, ganz, ganz, ganz toll.
Gibt es überhaupt noch eine Existenzberechtigung für WinRAR?
Ich meine, ich kann einfach 7-Zip installieren und gut ist.
Also eigentlich gibt es, oder?
Sehe ich das jetzt falsch? Eigentlich gibt es überhaupt keinen Grund.
Was die WinRAR CD ist da? Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt noch kurz an.
Wir pegen abwarten.
I apologize about the delay. I know you've all been keen to see this, but it's only just arrived. All the way from California. I won't keep you waiting, so let's unbox this mother and boot her up.
And there it is, an actual WinRAR CD.
Das ist eine selbstgebrannte CD.
Die haben die CD gebrannt bei sich daheim.
Hättet ihr überhaupt noch die Möglichkeit, das zu machen, was er hier macht?
Ich habe kein CD-Laufwerk mehr. Noch nicht mal ein USB-CD-Laufwerk. Ich habe nichts mehr.
Oh!
Grandios!
Also Eax, du hast echt noch ein CD-Laufwerk.
Oh! Monkeys!
Hä?
Windows-Logik.
Naja.
AI-Magic makes pictures better. Ich bezweifle, dass das Picture danach so aussieht von ihm.
Das macht eher das Picture von da nach da.
Ja, ja.
Und wie sieht's hier aus?
Okay, die feiern sich noch. Die feiern sich noch kurz. Na dann.
Hattest du mal ein Mac? Nee, hatte ich noch nie.
Ich hatte, ich habe nur mal versucht, oder ich hatte mal, was heißt versucht, das hat ja funktioniert.
Ich habe nur mal ein Mac OS auf einer Kiste hier installiert, auf so einem kleinen Mini-Desktop-Rechner.
Das hat auch funktioniert, aber ich habe es nie verwendet.
Was ist das? Windows XP Destruction.
Oh nee, das kann ich mir hier angucken.
Was findest du? Das ist Manjaro mit E3-WM und E-Knome-Terminal.
So.
Hattest du eigentlich schon mal einen Big Mac? Ja, hatte ich.
Aber einen Mac, so einen richtig echten, hatte ich noch nicht.
Ja, kein Kommentar.
Windows ME, hatte ich, klar, hatte ich Windows ME.
Okay, ich glaube, der Rest ist noch von vorher, das können wir eigentlich wegmachen.
Irgendjemand hat gerade den Anfang von Windows CD-Key reingeschrieben in den Chat vorhin.
Das waren die allerersten Windows XP Keys, die man gekannt hat, die sich überall aktivieren lassen.
Und ihr werdet lachen, zu Windows 98 Zeiten habe ich mein Windows 98 so oft installiert, und das ist jetzt kein Scherz.
Ich habe mein Windows 98 so oft installiert, ich kannte den CD-Key auswendig.
Hatte dieses Phänomen, hatte das noch irgendjemand?
Also Windows 98 kannte ich den CD-Key auswendig, Windows XP nicht, der E-AX, ja.
Du hast bestimmt auch viel installiert, gerade zu Windows 98.
Man hat den laufend neu installiert.
Du kennst dein WLAN-Passwort auswendig, das kenne ich auch auswendig.
So, also was haben wir noch, ein paar Stream-Ideen?
Wir haben ja noch eine Stunde Zeit, bis wir den Stream wirklich gucken müssen, weil vorher passiert da, was passiert da jetzt?
Wenn es wirklich passiert, tut er ja noch nichts.
720p, was ist denn mit denen los?
Ok, ja passiert noch nichts, ups.
1.20 noch.
Bis dann, Licky Brain.
Was haben wir noch?
Das mache ich heute nicht, auch falls der Patrick da ist und gleich wieder sagt Kobold.
Starcraft, wann habe ich denn schon mal Starcraft gespielt?
Soll ich dir Bescheid geben, wenn sie betankt wird? Kannst du machen, ja, ist eine gute Idee.
Aber ich gucke zwischendurch immer rein.
Das haben wir schon gemacht, WSL2 haben wir schon ausprobiert.
Frage zu meiner Gesellenprüfung. Kann sich Malware innerhalb eines Computers zwischen verschiedene Netzwerkkarten verbreiten?
Äh, wat?
Kann sich Malware innerhalb eines Computers zwischen verschiedene...
Also, dass sich die Malware auf einem Computer verbreitet, hat doch mit den Netzwerkarten überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht wirklich.
Dass du dich auf einem Computer verbreiten kannst, musst du ja nicht aus der einen Netzwerkkarte raus in die andere irgendwie wieder rein oder so, ja.
Aber gehen wir mal von aus, man hätte es geschafft, dass du irgendwie was eingeschleust hast auf einem Rechner.
Und es gibt in Windows irgendwie einen Root-Exploit im Netzwerk-Stack.
Dann könntest du theoretisch bestimmt die Netzwerkkarte ansprechen und es da drüber auslösen oder so.
Das ist aber eine komische Frage.
Also, theoretisch gehen die... das ist so ein bisschen wie bei der IHK-Prüfung. Man weiß nicht so genau, was der Frager hören will.
Benutzst du Puppet? Ja.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit eine riesen Puppet-Codebase.
Wobei sagt man heute, heute drückt man das ja viel cooler aus, das ist Infrastructure as Code.
Und die coolen Leute machen das heute alles in Jammern, aber Puppet ist ja so ein eigener Dialekt.
Aber wir haben sehr viel, sehr viel Puppet. Warum fragst du? Willst du was wissen?
Also ich bin jetzt nicht so der wahnsinnige Puppet-Pro, was die letzten Versionen angeht.
Ich hab das so ein bisschen ignoriert. Ich muss mir bloß öfter das Puppet-Code durchlesen.
Die Hälfte der Ideen würde eine VM brauchen. Ja klar, das meiste braucht eine VM.
Die Kautz fragt...
Ist für mich schon länger her, dass ich mir einen Laptop geholt habe, aber ich muss mir jetzt einen für die Uni zulegen.
Kannst du was qualitativ Hochwertiges empfehlen? Was benutzt ihr so?
Also ich hab gar kein Notebook. Also privat hab ich gar kein Notebook.
Ich kann ja auch nichts empfehlen. Was wir auf der Arbeit haben, sind Lenovo Thinkpads.
Frag mich aber nicht, welches Modell.
Hast du das Interlinux schon probiert? Nee, will ich auch nicht. Das ist glaube ich ziemlicher Crap.
Ich hab da ein paar Sachen mal drüber gelesen.
Ah, okay. Redhead sagt, es geht bei mir darum, dass ich WLAN im Netzwerk implementiert habe
und innerhalb des Netzwerks die verschiedenen WLANs in einem Windows-Server-PC zusammenlaufen.
Ja, das würde schon funktionieren. Also wenn du... Warum sieht dein Windows-PC überhaupt die WLANs?
Normalerweise wird das auf dem Switchport konfiguriert und der Rechner da dranhängt, bekommt davon gar nichts mit.
Aber gehen wir mal von aus, du hast verschiedene WLANs angestöpselt an unterschiedlichen Netzwerkkarten von einem Windows-PC.
Ja, wenn du dir irgendeinen Virus einfängst, Malware oder Trojaner-mäßig oder was ja ganz angesagt ist,
so zeigt irgendwelche Software die Daten verschlüsselt.
Im Allgemeinen, du hast einen NAS in dem einen WLAN, einen NAS in dem anderen WLAN, dann ist das gar kein Problem,
dass du von dem Windows-Rechner auf unterschiedliche WLANs zugreifen kannst, solange der Windows-Rechner.
Also wenn der Windows-Rechner darauf zugreifen kann, dann kann das ein Trojaner, den du eingefangen hast, auch.
Schon Erfahrung mit Kubernetes? Es geht, es geht. Wir haben eine Kubernetes-Installation bei uns im Rechtszentrum.
Da kümmert sich ein Dienstleister drum. Das ist so quasi die Cloud-Lite-Variante.
Es ist unsere Hardware, aber wir können sagen, es ist so eine Art Cloud. Und wir haben noch Kubernetes in Azure.
AKS, Azure Kubernetes Service, haben wir auch noch welche. Und das meiste läuft noch quasi bei dem selbstgestrickten Kubernetes.
Aber es wird immer mehr nach Azure gerade geschoben. So à la OwnCloud, ich weiß nicht was du meinst.
Das ist eine gute Frage. AWS, Azure oder Google Cloud? Wo fange ich denn da am besten an?
Als erstes muss ich dazu sagen, dass ich da nicht der Beste bin, das objektiv zu vergleichen, weil ich habe beispielsweise AWS so gut wie nicht benutzt.
Das Einzige, was ich in AWS gemacht habe, ist S3-mäßig was zu speichern bisher.
Die Amazon Cloud-Service-Geschichte habe ich noch nicht wirklich verwendet.
Was ich verwendet habe ist privat Google Cloud mit ein paar VMs und auch die ganzen Google API-Geschichten, die es da drinne gibt.
Von Maps bis Adress-Validierung und sonst was. Und auf der Arbeit relativ viel Azure.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, so viel nimmt sich das eigentlich nicht.
Du hast bei Google eine Administrationskonsole, du hast bei Azure eine Administrationskonsole.
Es kostet bei allen Services quasi fast jeder Furz, den du lässt in der Cloud irgendwo irgendwas.
Und sonderlich transparent finde ich die Preisbestaltung weder bei Azure noch bei Google Cloud.
Also ehrlich gesagt nimmt sich nicht so viel. Der Hype ist vielleicht ein bisschen auf der Seite von Azure aktuell.
Wenn du so rumguckst, die halbe Welt redet über Azure, vor allem Kubernetes in Azure und sonst was.
Dabei hat Google Cloud das genauso. Aber ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt nicht, warum man das eine nehmen sollte und das andere nicht und umgedreht.
Oder Chat, was sagt ihr? Das sind so meine Erfahrungen dazu.
Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt auch nicht alle drei im Businessumfeld irgendwie verglichen. Ich würde sagen, so viel nimmt sich das jetzt nicht.
Ja gut und zur Amazon kann ich halt echt nicht so viel sagen.
Der Hacker Mans. Es gibt ja noch mehr Plattformen.
Ach ja, ich wollte mal gucken. Stimmt. Wie sind denn eigentlich so bei der Hetzner Cloud mittlerweile die Preise?
Letztes Mal waren die ziemlich nice. Mal gucken, ob die immer noch so sind.
Weil ich muss mal wieder OpenStreetMaps. Ist jetzt schon zwei Monate her oder so.
Ich muss mal wieder OpenStreetMaps-Hooting-Informationen processen. Da brauche ich wieder eine ordentliche VM zu.
Also ich brauche mindestens 96 Gigabyte RAM.
Da ist das hier schon mal nix.
Ja, sowas hier brauche ich. Die da. GIF.
Die. Okay, die Preise sind immer noch relativ gut.
32 Kerne, 128 Gigabyte RAM und 600 Gigabyte SSD.
Das heißt, das ist wahrscheinlich in 2-3 Stunden processed.
Das ist richtig nice. Dann bezahle ich einen Euro. Ich bezahle 1-2 Euro.
Das ist die Hälfte von DigitalOcean.
Weil ich jetzt nicht komplett falsch lege.
Ja, guck mal. Das ist ungefähr ein gutes 1 Euro.
Es ist ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte von was ich bei DigitalOcean bezahlen würde.
Also ich muss sagen, die Hetzner Cloud-Preise sind echt nicht übel.
Und gerade der hier ist gut. Das ist genau das. Geh mal fort.
Das ist genau das, was ich für meine Anwendungszwecke brauche. Die fette Kiste. Passt wunderbar.
Was für Prozesse willst du auslagern? Gar nicht.
Ich muss doch einmal im Monat, so ungefähr, OpenStreetMaps-Rooting-Daten neu preprocessen lassen, dass ich sie verwenden kann.
Und das geht da halt schön schnell. Bei mir lokal dauert das ewig.
Ich habe keinen Rechner bei mir daheim, der 100 GB Arbeitsspeicher hat.
Und selbst mit Auslagerungsdatei auf einer SSD ist es unglaublich langsam.
Wofür braucht ihr die OpenStreetMaps-Daten?
Ich habe mit einem Arbeitskollege zusammen eine Anwendung gebastelt, mit der Handwerker sich Routen zu Kunden berechnen lassen können.
Also möglichst optimalen Weg, wie sie ihre Kunden besuchen können.
Also sprich, du hast im Prinzip eine große Tabelle, wo du alle deine Kunden drin hast, so eine Kundenverwaltung light.
Und dann addest du die einfach und sagst hier, okay, man müsste mal wieder Frau Müller, Frau Meyer, bla, XY besuchen, die müsste man mal wieder besuchen.
Berechne mir mal eine Route und dann berechnet er halt eine recht gute Route, wie man am besten fährt, sodass man halt möglichst wenig hin und herfahren muss und dass man die Termine einhalten kann halbwegs.
Meinst du, das könnte man in Medizintechnik nehmen für ärztliche Hausbesuche?
Ja, klar, da ist es sogar noch besser.
Das funktioniert sogar noch viel besser für Hausbesuche, weil Hausbesuche sind immer relativ in der Nähe.
Die Installateure können ja theoretisch durch ganz Deutschland fahren.
Aber man kann das für ziemlich alles nennen, das Problem nennt sich, ich habe es vergessen, Travelling Salesman ist so die kleine Variante davon, wie heißt denn das große?
Hier, vehicle routing problem with time window oder sowas, genau. Das da ist das eigentliche Problem, was du suchst und das kann man im Prinzip auf alle möglichen Anwendungen übertragen.
Time window ist halt die Zeit, wo du da sein musst und hier bei vehicle routing ist halt im Vergleich zu diesem Standard Travelling Salesman Problem, was man hat, dass man hier auch mehrere Autos haben kann,
wohingegen der Salesman immer alleine travelt.
Und wie schaut es aus?
Poggers Touchscreens hier, guckt es euch mal an, sieht man schon weg.
Es gab irgendeine Frage im Chat, ich habe es aber übersehen und jetzt finde ich sie nicht mehr.
Ah ja genau, Flo96 sagt gibt es für diese Probleme nicht schon längst, Google Maps halbe halbe.
Google Maps verwende ich für Adressvervollständigung, wunderbar.
Ansonsten sind die anderen Sachen, wenn man viel braucht, ziemlich teuer.
Google Maps ist so ein Ding, es sieht erstmal so aus, als ist es umsonst, weil du glaube 200 Euro im Monat gratis hast.
Aber ich habe es gesehen, allein schon beim testen habe ich relativ schnell 15 Euro verbraucht, nach ein paar Tagen, weil ich halt viele Testabfragen gemacht habe,
weil ich halt einfach am entwickeln war und guck musste, wie das funktioniert.
Das ist relativ schnell ziemlich teuer wert.
Und dieses Problem selbst, was ich hier gerade beschrieben habe, sprich Routenoptimierung inklusive Zeitfenster hat Google Maps nicht.
Man kann das allerdings über die Google API machen, aber mit Zusatzgeschichten und jeder Request kostet Geld.
Das heißt im Endeffekt wird es relativ teuer das ganze über Google zu machen.
Das heißt, warum sollten wir es nicht über OpenStreetView machen, wenn es das komplett kostenlos gibt.
Das Einzige, was man bei OpenStreetView halt braucht, um die Routinginformation sinnvoll verwenden zu können, ist,
man muss sich einmal alle, einmal alle Monat oder zwei Monate eine fette VM holen, um die Routinginformation zu processen.
Laufen lassen kann man die Anwendung dann auch auf einem normalen Rechner mit SSD, das ist kein Problem.
Aber das Processen von den Routinginformationen, das braucht eine ganze Weile.
Ich zeige euch mal, was ich dafür verwende.
Das da.
Wie findest du eigentlich Opera GX als Browser?
Wir haben es mal ausprobiert, ich habe nichts gefunden, was mich überzeugt hat.
Genau, also sprich, das ist hier so ein Docker-Container für OpenStreetMaps Routing.
Und die sagen ja hier auch, man braucht sehr viel RAM.
Memory, Memory, Memory.
Hä?
Ok, was auch immer, warum die das nicht reingeschrieben haben.
Aber man braucht sehr viel RAM.
Also ich processe aktuell Europa und ich komme so mit 90 GB ganz gut hin.
90 GB RAM wohlgemerkt.
Und nachdem man das processed hat, dann gibt es ein paar Dateien.
Und wenn man diese Sachen dann quasi einfach von der SSD laufen, das ist vollkommen ok.
Geht auch halbwegs schnell.
Aber das Preprocessen der ganzen OpenStreetMaps Information, das braucht RAM ohne Ende.
Und deswegen mache ich das immer in irgendeiner Cloud-VM.
Ja, Haclo macht so. Sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Ja, Flow690, Google gibt glaube ich 200 Euro im Monat, 200 Dollar Credits.
Oder 300 Dollar Credits, also sprich, wenn du es nicht aufbrauchst, ist es nicht so, als würde Google das Geld ausbezahlen oder so.
Rate mal, wie viel Speicher der 5G-Biosheet-USB-Stick hat. Ich wollte gerade sagen 128 MB, weil das habe ich vorher schon mal gelesen.
Wie groß sind die finalen Daten? Ich weiß es gar nicht jetzt genau.
Ich glaube 80 GB? Irgendwie so. Was, in 3 Minuten? What the fuck?
In 3 Minuten? Was? Nee, nee, 21 Uhr 22.
Das ist Jebait. Echt? Okay, dann haben die sich vielleicht auch versprochen.
BlitzBullet hostet mich für 3 Zuschauer. Excellent Host.
Huge Host. Massive. Dankeschön.
Nie im Leben starten die in 3 Minuten?
Starten in der Stunde, genau, genau, genau, genau. So sieht es aus.
Die haben noch nicht mal vollgetankt. Wir hatten einen kurzen Flug.
Ich hoffe es ja nicht, also ich hoffe ja echt nicht, dass etwas in die Hose geht.
Also, nicht das, sondern dass da ein Kram explodiert.
Das wäre nicht so schön.
Doch, diese Woche ist eins in die Luft geflogen. Allerdings eine komplett andere Rakete, als was sie hier verwenden.
Kannst du das mal in einem Stream zeigen, Captain Sieker? Was meinst du?
Ja, 21 Uhr 22 ist es. Dein OSMR Processing Zeug, das haben wir sogar schon mal im Stream gesehen.
Oder meinst du die Anwendung, die wir gebastelt haben? Die kann ich dir zeigen.
Ich muss nochmal gucken, ob sie gerade läuft. Oh fuck, ich weiß mein Passwort nicht mehr.
CACW, ich kann es dir nicht zeigen. Ich weiß das Passwort nicht mehr von der Basic-Authentifizierung, die ich davor gemacht habe.
Das ist ein Test bestimmt. Fuck, never.
Ich hab die doch schon mal im Stream gezeigt.
Ich weiß das Passwort nicht mehr aus dem Kopf.
Sonst hätte ich es euch noch mal gezeigt, aber ich habe es schon mal irgendwo gezeigt.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich das hier irgendwo finde. Man kann ja Clips nicht durchsuchen, oder?
Ja, die neue Twitch leckt bei euch auch das neue Twitch Profil so krass. Ist doch nicht normal.
Wir haben uns schon mal Venis Unleashed angeschaut, ja vor vier Jahren oder so. Aber das ist ja irgendwie tot, da kommt ja nichts mehr.
Ob die Piloten Netflix auf dem Monitor anschauen können? Mich würde viel eher interessieren, ob sie sich Twitch anschauen können.
Die Post-It-State kommt in 45 Minuten. Nice. Excellent.
Was habe ich da für ein Passwort genommen? Das war so ein richtig dummes Passwort, das weiß ich noch.
Das war so ein richtig dummes Passwort, Tests. Nee, ich kriege es nicht hin.
Nein, nein, das war schon ein sinnvolles Passwort, aber ein richtig dummes, sinnvolles Passwort.
Es wäre nicht schlecht, wenn ich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Bitrate bzw. Auflösung für den Stream machen würde.
Ja, ist noch nicht so weit. Ein richtig dummes Passwort, genau so in der Richtung war es Rig 535. In diese Richtung ging es.
Hi, wie geht es? Mir geht es gut. Excellent. Ich habe gerade etwas gefuttert, bin schon ziemlich lange im Stream am Start.
Guck mal hier, 4 Stunden. Was ist denn heute los? Und davon vielleicht 2 Stunden was Sinnvolles gemacht?
Haben die Windows XP Updates funktioniert? Ja, haben sie. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, aber haben sie.
Ich muss das doch finden bei mir. In welchem Stream habe ich das denn gezeigt?
Da gab es auch Clips zu, aber das ist schon ein bisschen her. Das ist schon 2-3 Monate her, wo ich das gezeigt habe.
Clips. Hoffen wir mal, dass ein paar Leute den Clip gesehen haben. Deswegen machen wir einfach mal alle Clips, aber wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Ich scroll mal kurz drüber, ob ich irgendwas sehe. Warum haben manche Sachen so viele Views hier?
Was zur Hölle machst du da, Max? Ja, das frage ich mich auch öfters mal. Das frage ich mich öfters. Ein BDO Stream ist ja schon ewig her.
Hier BDO habe ich ja von. Ich kenne den Clip. Das ist wo ich erzählt habe, dass mein Klo gebrannt hat.
Oder dass mein Klo brennen kann. Ich habe gestern einen Anruf gekriegt von dem Typ, der mein Klo eingebaut hat.
Jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt es. Mein Klo kann unter seltenen Umständen anfangen zu brennen, hat er mir erzählt.
Stellt euch das mal vor. Der Klo kann quasi die Wohnung abfackeln. Ja, das stimmt.
Mittlerweile war der Techniker da und hat es gefixt.
Vielleicht hat das doch irgendjemand geklippt, wo ich das gezeigt habe. Dann kann ich es dir noch mal zeigen.
Ich sehe das sofort in der Vorschau, wenn ich es richtig erkenne.
Weil das so eine hässliche Material Design Anwendung ist, das erkenne ich sofort.
LED-Toilette.
Wie viele Clips sich hier angesammelt haben.
Poggers. Ich frage mich, ob es einen französischen Poggers gibt. Ist das dann Poggers?
Warum eigentlich Chromium und nicht Chrome? Ursprünglich mal, weil ich kein Chromecast Geschichten haben wollte im Browser.
Mittlerweile habe ich mich daran gewöhnt.
Das ist das Hardware-Tool. Ich erkenne ja zum größten Teil, was man auf der Vorschau sieht.
Aber das andere war bis jetzt noch nicht dabei.
Das sind noch zwei Jahre her, das kann nicht sein. Das ist zu lang. Das ist World at War.
Das sechs Monate der letzten Monat Scheiß-Clone.
Heiligabend-Stream.
Wann ist noch mal diese PS5-Stream am Donnerstag?
Wie viel Uhr ist das noch mal? Uhrzeit? 22 Uhr. 22 Uhr Donnerstag.
Das ist schon... 22 Uhr.
Das ist aber der Scheißzeit. Donnerstag, 22 Uhr. Da bin ich ja schon quasi fast im Bett.
Ach, da haben wir mal... Da haben wir mal Realm Royale gespielt. Kannst du dich noch dran erinnern? The Fork. Sets in oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist auch so ein Game, was wir voll verkackt haben.
Da sind ja unendlich viele Clips, die wir hier mittlerweile haben. Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Das war ein...
Das ist die Battlefield-Beta, wo ich mich voll aufgeregt habe.
Ey, so viele Clips.
Mach am Freitag Homeoffice. Naja, ich hab ja Dauer-Homeoffice. Das ist also als Dämengesichtspunkt kein Problem, aber dann muss ich später anfangen, muss ich länger auf der Arbeit bleiben. Oder länger on bleiben.
Oh, wir haben Overwatch-Placements gestreamt. Ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern. MonkaS, Overwatch-Placements.
Also, wer auch immer das wissen wollte, ich finde es nicht. Es haben garantiert Leute geklippt. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher sogar.
Aber...
Oh, du siehst, wie viele Clips hier gibt. Da blickst du nicht mehr durch. Das war erst letztens Telekom.
Aufwachen-Stream, Kokona.
Oh...
Guck mal da, meine Katze. Ist ja nicht niedlich, hä? Was macht denn die Rakete? Die Rakete steht da 48 Minuten noch.
Du hast mal Plants vs. Zombies gespielt. Anscheinend, ja. Sehe ich auch gerade.
Kann ich mich auch nicht mehr dran erinnern, dass ich mal Plants vs. Zombies gestreamt hab.
Kicks not hot.
Was ist das hier? Ah, das ist auch Battlefield.
Guck mal, wie wir Overwatch-Rank gespielt haben, einfach mal. Sogar relativ viel, ne?
Wir haben auch mal kurz PUBG gespielt, aber da habe ich festgestellt, das ist einfach nicht mein Game.
Overwatch, richtig Dead Game.
Also, das ist das lebendigste tote Spiel aller Zeiten, Overwatch.
Es spielen irgendwie, so Zombies spielen Overwatch noch.
Die noch nicht wahr haben wollen, dass es tot ist.
Ja, gleich wieder geschlossen, kann ich verstehen.
Also, es gibt ja auch quasi keinen Hype um Overwatch 2, ne?
Es hat wirklich, die haben Overwatch 2 angekündigt und es hat niemand gehypt.
Es haben alle nur da gesagt so, aha, okay, naja, blöd an.
Crimzix, ja, ich heiße ja hier auch anders. Aber schön, dass du auch den Weg gefunden hast.
Was macht denn eigentlich die Rakete? Die steht noch da, wir haben nichts verpasst.
Ich bin ja gerade echt auch voll geschockt, wie viele Clips es mittlerweile gibt auf dem Channel.
Aber gut, ich meine, ich bin ja schon seit zwei Jahren oder drei Jahren fast schon jetzt mittlerweile am Start.
Die Zeit ging deutlich schneller rum, als ich gedacht habe.
Stellenangebote angucken, haben wir auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht, müssen wir mal wieder machen.
Oh, der Pfeiffer, MonkaS, gehst du weg.
Immer wenn man nicht mit ihm rechnet, taucht er auf.
Auf den Stream Bewerbung schreiben, na das wird es in nächster Zeit wahrscheinlich nicht geben.
Ich bin ja da relativ zufrieden, wo ich jetzt bin.
Das heißt, ich habe eigentlich gar keinen Grund, mich da jetzt zur Zeit woanders zu bewerben.
Zumal ich ja jetzt seit letztem Jahr sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Geld kriege.
Das heißt, wenn es dann ab und zu noch mal ein bisschen mehr Kohle gibt, dann bin ich da voll und ganz zufrieden.
Ich dachte, ich hätte was gefunden, aber das war es nicht.
Wow.
Aber heftig, wie viele Clips.
Ah, hier, das ist das Hardware-Tool.
Mist, verguckt.
Fast.
Na gut, scheiß drauf, ich finde es nicht.
EA Bullshit Bingo.
Oh, das habe ich ja schon wieder voll vergessen.
Wir haben ja To The Moon gestreamt.
Oh, das ist auch so, das ist richtig Massive Pepehands-Game.
War jemand von euch überhaupt in dem Stream dabei? Das ist zwei Jahre her.
So ein tolles Game, es ist kein richtiges Spiel, aber so eine super Story.
Clip anschauen.
Ach nee, das ist das Intro, da passiert noch gar nichts.
Ah, hier war ich noch bei der Telekom und da hat die Telekom gesackt.
BF3 Easy Clip, okay, waren das jetzt alle Clips?
Ich glaube einfach nur, dass es nicht genug geladen hat, dass es verbackt ist.
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass es drei Views hat beim wenigsten geschauten Clip.
Na ja.
So, Rakete, die sitzen immer noch da drinnen.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich meine, wo sollen sie hin?
Noch 40 Minuten Leute, dann geht's los.
Fast, ja.
Können die ein bisschen lauter reden?
Wo fliegen die denn eigentlich hin?
Ich wollte gerade auch was total Bescheuertes sagen.
Sie sollen nicht zur Raumstation fliegen.
Hallo, what the fuck?
YouTube, please.
Stell dir vor, du musst 18 Stunden da drinnen jetzt die Monitore anschauen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich müssen die sich die Monitore gar nicht anschauen, das ist einfach nur Show.
Weil sich die ganze Crown Crew wahrscheinlich die wichtigen Sachen anguckt.
Bei denen reicht's schon, wenn die einfach nur drinnen sitzen und im Zweifelsfall draufgehen.
Also ich hab ja die Pre-Shows mir noch nie großartig angeguckt.
Ich glaube, dass die Pre-Show oder die Show bevor das Ding dann startet,
im Prinzip einfach nur ein langer Werbefilm ist für SpaceX.
Erstmal solitär spielen.
Ja, das läuft ja auch mit Windows.
Also wenn das mit Windows fliegen würde, ich sag euch, ich würde nicht fliegen.
Was sind das denn für Showklappen, die da ein neuer Monitor an der Seite hat?
Ich glaube, sie nennen das irgendwie Focus Shields.
Das sind einfach Plastikklappen, dass du nichts links und rechts siehst.
Ich glaube, das hat zwei Gründe.
Einmal, weil das ein Monitor ist, den sie auch auf Turnieren verwenden wollen.
Und da ist es manchmal ganz gut, wenn man nicht links und rechts gucken kann.
Dass man sich selbst besser fokussieren kann, wenn man noch andere Sachen drum herum stehen hat.
Und wahrscheinlich, weil es irgendwie so aussieht, als wäre es was Tolles.
Ich werde es nicht dran machen.
Ja, ich hoffe nicht, dass die absagen.
Dann haben wir jetzt hier eine Stunde umsonst gesessen.
Aber wo wir gerade dabei sind, wir gucken mal bei Alternate, was mein Monitor macht.
Also ob der bei Alternate jetzt auf Lieferbar steht.
Ne, Vorbestellen, Vorbestellen Juni, okay.
Na dann, mal abwarten.
Sie haben geschrieben, dass es zwischen 30. Mai und 1. Juni ankommt.
Ich glaube aber, dass die Sache bei Alternate irgendwie ein bisschen fail ist und eine automatisch generierte Mail.
Weil, wenn die Lieferung, also wenn die Vorbestellt haben und Alternate bekommt irgendwann im Juni die Lieferung.
Es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass am 1. Juni ich den Monitor schon habe.
Kein 4K, die haben nur einen 720p Stream.
Die sind nicht technologisch auf der Höhe der Zeit genug, um einen ordentlichen Stream anzubieten.
Aber eine Rakete können sie bauen.
Und wenn ich jetzt mal angenommen, ich wäre der Astronaut, der da drin sitzt.
Mir wäre es auch lieber, sie könnten ordentliche Rakete bauen, anstatt einen ordentlichen Stream zu machen.
Alternate keine Versandbestätigung.
Hätte mich jetzt auch echt sehr gewundert.
Rakete konnten die vor ein paar Jahren bauen, das ist aber eine andere Rakete als vor ein paar Jahren.
Und dass Raketebau nicht so easy ist, hat man gesehen.
Der Kram ist ja heute in die Luft geflogen.
John hat eine DVD, ist im Twitch Chat gesperrt.
Er hat mir eine Mail geschickt.
Warum ist denn der?
Mods, habt ihr eine Ahnung, warum der im Twitch Chat gesperrt ist?
Hat er was angestellt oder habe ich ihn aus Versehen angeklickt?
Nee, ich hab gerade in meine Mails reingeguckt.
An.
Anbann.
Ah, er ist aufgehoben.
Ich hab ihn mal unbanned.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum der gebannt ist.
Ich schreibe immer, dass ich ihn entbannt hab.
Wenn er wirklich was angestellt hat, dann natürlich nicht, aber ich glaube nicht.
Tja.
So.
Das ist natürlich wichtig, dass es aus.
Kommt.
So.
Hell yeah.
Sneaky Boy ist noch nicht so ganz raus.
Jetzt bräuchte man den Barbecue Pit Boys Typ, der im Hintergrund macht.
Ah, schau dir das an.
Okay.
Da passiert noch nicht so viel.
Da passiert nicht mehr noch nicht allzu viel.
Die sind noch am.
Kona feiern.
Kannst du nicht MP3 Soundboard machen?
Doch, könnte ich.
Kann man sich auflisten lassen, wer alles gebannt ist?
Auf Twitch.
Nicht, dass ich noch mehr aus Versehen geblockt habe.
Durch durch sinnloses rumgeklickt im Chat.
Kommt man das irgendwo sieht.
Wenn er sie dahinter ist schon erst ist er sie dahinter, aber ich glaube nicht, dass diese Sachen unterstützt werden.
Twitch sie ist blockt.
Na ja, nachdem der Eier seat runter ist, kann es das ja ohne Probleme machen.
Das gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Was?
Was zum Teufel?
Das gibt es ja nicht mehr, es gibt nur das Creator Dashboard.
Dann haben wir hier Community.
Keine Ahnung.
Tatsächlich.
Wir haben ja schon einige geblockt hier.
Wir haben ja schon einige geblockt.
An manche Extrem-Spammer kann ich mich sogar noch erinnern.
Aber nice, Poggers.
Ne, so viel ist gar nicht.
Leider hat er immer meine Nachricht übersehen, was denn?
Was hast du denn, was wolltest du denn wissen?
Alles sehe ich auch nicht.
Fliegt die Crew zur ISS, ja.
Ja, Zepcon, was gibt es denn, schieß los.
Das Gute ist, wenn du Ed Wublos schreibst, dann kommt das hier rein.
Na, wenn ich es natürlich nicht zeitnah sehe, dann kann es sein, dass ich aus Versehen auch mit gelöscht habe.
Aber ich versuche ja alles zu beantworten, was an Fragen so gibt, aber manchmal geht halt auch einfach was unter.
Es gibt zwei Varianten, wenn ich Fragen nicht beantworte.
Manche Fragen oder manche Sachen sind so bescheuert gestellt, gefragt, was auch immer, dass ich keinen Bock habe, sie zu beantworten.
Aber auch keinen Bock habe, was zu sagen und deswegen ignoriere ich sie einfach.
Oder aber das meiste, was ich nicht beantworte, habe ich schlicht und greiflich nicht gesehen.
Wenn du eine Sache an Windows ändern könntest, was wäre das?
Boah, da muss ich mir Gedanken machen.
Eine Sache an Windows.
Ich meine, was wahrscheinlich nicht zählt ist, dass ich eine Sache ändern würde, dass ich mehrere Sachen ändern könnte.
Das ist ja so wie, du hast drei Wünsche und ich wünsche mir mehr Wünsche.
Das zählt, das geht ja nicht.
Ich würde mir da was relativ abstraktes wünschen, ehrlich gesagt.
Und zwar, dass Microsoft wieder realisiert, dass Windows für ein Desktop ist.
Und auch, die alles darauf auslegt, aber das werden sie nicht machen.
Also sie sollten wieder mehr Fokus darauf setzen, dass das Scheiß ordentlich funktioniert auf dem Desktop.
Dazu gehört ja vieles.
Ein ordentliches UI-Framework, was wieder mal richtig funktioniert, WinUI vielleicht mal irgendwann.
Ganze Touch-Tablet-Gedöns brauche ich auf dem Desktop nicht.
Nice to have, sage ich nichts dagegen, dass das da ist.
Es gibt ja genug Leute, die haben mittlerweile sogar einen Touchscreen-Monitor oder so.
Aber man sollte sich darauf konzentrieren, dass die Hauptsache wieder für Desktop sein sollte.
Es wurde auch so viel zurückgefahren unter Windows 10.
Überlegt euch mal, wir haben es uns ja vorher kurz angeguckt, wie cool man Windows XP customisieren konnte und Windows 10 kannst du nichts customisieren.
Geil wäre mal Schnittstellen zwischen Apple iPhones und Windows, naja.
Also der ZappCore hat gefragt, du hattest mal so eine Funktionalität, wo man Steuerung plus mittlere Maustaste benutzen kann, um Fenster in ihrer Größe zu verändern.
Geht das auch bei Windows? Nee.
Das geht nicht bei Windows. Was du meinst, ist das hier.
Na, Windows-Taste und rechte Maustaste ist das.
Das habe ich hier unter meinem E3, unter Linux.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es einen entsprechenden Shortcut für Windows gibt.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, das ist zu big brain.
Es gibt mit Sicherheit Addons, die das können, unter Windows, weiß ich nicht.
Benutzt du Vim? Ja, zum größten Teil für kleine Sachen, was ich auf der Kommandozeile editieren muss.
Also alles, was ich auf der Kommandozeile editiere oder auf Server-Remote editiere, mache ich mit Vim.
Aber ansonsten verwende ich mittlerweile hauptsächlich VS Code.
Ich habe früher auch total darauf geschworen, alles in Vim zu machen, aber das ist mir einfach mit der Zeit zu anstrengend geworden.
Gerade weil das Ökosystem an Vim-Plugins, es ist zwar riesig, aber die Qualität ist oftmals fragwürdig und die Dinge funktionieren oftmals nicht richtig konsistent miteinander.
So, machen wir mal hier Sound an.
Was? Der Meatball? Excellent.
Welcher Meatball? Wir hatten vorher bei den Barbecue Pit Boys ein Meatball.
Der Boss ist back, was für eine Umfrage.
Vim ist nicht größer Whistle Studio. Genauso wenig wie Whistle Studio größer Vim ist. Es kommt auf den Anwendungszweck an.
Wenn es um.NET Programme erstellen geht, ist Whistle Studio eindeutig größer Vim.
Oh, die ist ja hübsch. Wer ist das denn? Tarilla Allen von der NASA. Excellent.
Also im Prinzip geht es immer darum, was das Richtige ist für den jeweiligen Anwendungszweck.
Und wenn es.NET Programme sind, dann ist Whistle Studio das Richtige und wenn es auf Serverseite Textdateien editieren ist, dann halt Vim.
Sprich überhaupt nichts dagegen, einfach das passende Tool zu verwenden für den Anwendungszweck.
So ein zwungener Smalltalk davor immer.
Wann ist Lift-Off in? Wenn alles glatt geht, in 22 Minuten.
Wie es kommt mit Vim add-on, why not? Ja, kann man machen.
Es fühlt sich aber komisch an. Weil einige Funktionen, die Vim ausmachen, sind in Whistle Studio schlicht und ergreifend so nicht zu implementieren.
Zum Beispiel das Verstecken von einzelnen Buchstaben und so, was manche add-ons verwenden.
Das funktioniert dann schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Kann man machen, aber ich finde ehrlich gesagt, dass sich Vim zum größten Teil außerhalb von Vim irgendwie out of place anfühlt.
Guck mal, der wirft die Rakete gleich um.
Aber ich brauch den Smalltalk davor echt nicht.
Sind die Emotes kleiner geworden? Welche?
Im Chat? Ich glaube, du hast einfach den Zoom-Level hochgestellt oder runtergestellt.
Nee, im Chat, die sind alle gleich groß.
Nee, da ist kein Unterschied.
Was hat denn der da leuchten auf dem Bildschirm?
Die haben bestimmt auch nur heute Anzug an.
Subhype? Ich sehe keine Subs.
Was ich sehe ist, dass er hier dran hat gesagt, falls ich ihn vorhin übersehen habe. Dankeschön. Exzellent.
Wie fliegt man eigentlich zu ISS?
Nur mal so von der Theorie.
Also mal angenommen, hier ist die Erde. Exzellent. Exquisite Erde.
Und hier ist NA. Da starten die.
Und sagen wir mal, die Erde dreht sich so rum. Die Raumstation ist hier.
Exzellent Raumstation. Wenn die jetzt starten, fliegen die dann quasi in, in, in. Also die Raumstation fliegt ja auch so rum, sagen wir mal so.
Also worauf ich raus will ist, fliegen die der Raumstation entgegen oder fliegen die quasi mit der Raumstation, dass sie da drankommt.
Die müssen eigentlich hinterher fliegen, weil die können ja nicht umdrehen.
Also die müssen da hinterher fliegen. Weil wenn die, wenn die, wenn die der entgegen fliegen wollen, die können ja schlecht bremsen.
Ja. Sie fliegen hinterher. Okay ja dann. Dann ergibt das Sinn, was ich mir ja auch gerade überlegt habe. Ja.
Ja, ansonsten wird es ja auch gar nicht funktionieren. Die können ja schlecht sagen, ach guck mal, da kommt die Raumstation. Bremsen und volle Kerne nach links.
Es ist halt schwierig bei, weiß nicht wie schnell die sind. 70.000 Stundenkilometer oder mehr wahrscheinlich, wenn beide fliegen. 100.000 Stundenkilometer quasi.
Eine in die eine Richtung, eine in die andere Richtung. Flup. Das ist ganz schön schnell vorbei.
Da bremst du immer nicht nebenbei. Ja zusammenrennen sollten sie auch nicht. Das wäre auch schlecht.
Max spielt Kerbal Space Program. Nein, noch nie. Ich wollte schon ewig mehr angucken, das Spiel. Aber ich habe Angst, dass es ein bisschen, ein bisschen wie Factorio ist.
Wenn du mit Factorio erstmal anfängst, ist dein Leben eigentlich vorbei. Was genau ist der Plan, das Ziel beim Flug? Die wollen zur internationalen Raumstation fliegen.
Ich bin aber auch nicht der große Pro, also ich habe mich da wenig informiert drüber. Ich gucke einfach nur den Start, weil ich sowas gerne gucke und die letzten auch geguckt habe.
Aber um die Mission selbst, muss ich ehrlich sagen, habe ich mich wenig informiert.
Okay, 17 Minuten. Ist da Alan Musk mit drin? Ja, der hat hier oben so eine private Kapsel, da sitzt er drin.
Einzige Sache, die ich dazu jetzt halbwegs qualifiziert sagen kann, weil ich da mal ein Video zugesehen habe, aber zu einer anderen Rakete ist, die Rakete, warum die neben so qualmt ist, das Kühlmittel.
Und nicht, weil sie heiß ist. Das ist das Kühlmittel vom Treibstoff, weil der Treibstoff wahrscheinlich sonst entweder nicht funktioniert oder kaputt geht oder in die Luft fliegt oder sowas.
Wird die Rakete recycelt? Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube teilweise, die untere Hälfte wird irgendwie recycelt oder so.
Oder der Treibstoff selbst. Es ist zumindest, muss gekühlt werden. Oder muss kalt sein, wie auch immer.
Der Kommentator, das haben wir schon ausprobiert. Ich habe sie hingekriegt.
Können die das vielleicht unbedingt in den Lounge kokona? Das wird doch so eigentlich viel besser aussehen.
Du hast wieder deinen Kompressor drin. Immer, immer. Warum?
Ah, Leute, sagt mir noch was. Mein Mikrofon ist viel zu laut eingestellt. Kein Wunder, dass sich das wahrscheinlich kacke angehört hat.
Oh Gott, Schleim, Schleim, Schleim, Alter.
Wenn man bei einem öffentlichen Livestream mit seinem Chef schleimen muss.
Gleich geht es los. Was hat er denn da? Ah, so ein Checklist oder sowas.
Und was treiben die Jungs da oben rumfliegen? Mit 50.000 Stundenkilometer im Kreis.
Und wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Experimente machen.
Übernachtet Maske eigentlich noch im Tesla-Werk. Das war doch letztens so eine Marketing-Aktion, als es irgendwas bei Tesla nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Wo er gesagt hat, er übernachtet jetzt sogar da.
Also ich glaube, das ist der Teil, der wieder landet, oder?
Das hier unten.
Was macht er da? Okay, vielleicht ist er einfach nur ein bisschen nervös.
Luftgitarre-Spiel. Läuft die Gitarre mit Linux? Ich glaube, so ein traditionelles Betriebssystem, wie man das hier vom Desktop kennt, wird da nicht drauflaufen.
Das wird alles ziemlich Real-Time sein, was da passiert. Vielleicht läuft es ja auch in Kubernetes in Azure.
Ich meine, wenn die nicht in der Cloud sind, wer dann? Serverless, genau.
Ich hoffe, die haben ExpressVPN oben, dass man ihren Traffic nicht sehen kann. Oder NordVPN.
Also by the way, VPNs braucht kein Mensch, nur mal so angemerkt wieder.
Ob Astronauten Porn schauen dürfen? PC lustig. Also auf der Internationalen Raumstation haben die ja so Schlafkammern, so Säcke, sind so Kammern mit Reißverschluss, die du dazumachen kannst.
Und da kannst du ja ein paar private Sachen mitbringen. Vielleicht. Laptop haben sie da auch drin, vielleicht. Aber ich glaube, die haben da andere Sachen zu tun, oder die sind wahrscheinlich ziemlich im Arsch, als am Ende von so einem Tag als da Porn zu gucken.
Aber warum nicht? Gehen tut es bestimmt. Gehen tut es bestimmt. Vielleicht schauen die auch Pokimane oder so. Nein, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, was die da treiben.
Ich will es auch gar nicht so genau wissen.
Dann chillt mal die Engine.
Moment, Moment, wir müssen unseren Kokona umschieben.
So, gleich haben wir es.
Ich gehe jetzt ab. Ich war ganz schön lang online heute und wirklich viel Sinnvolles gemacht haben wir dazu. Wir haben ja nicht außer die ersten zweieinhalb Stunden.
Was sagt das Wetter?
Hoffentlich starten die heute.
Du hast die Bitrate runtergestellt. Löh habe ich nicht. Ich habe die Bitrate nicht runtergestellt. Sehbaro, guck mal hier.
4900. Ja, 4900 reicht für Desktop Stream aus.
Für Desktop Stream reicht das aus.
Wir haben mehr Leute gucken. Viele Leute haben Probleme mit 7 MBit in Deutschland leider.
7900 hatte ich nur für Games.
Für den Stream macht es überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob 4,9 MBit oder 7,9 MBit.
Zumal der Original Stream ist ja auch nur 720p 5 MBit oder so.
Excellent.
Was läuft da unten durch?
Die Katze ist gerade ins Zimmer gestellt gekommen.
Nico, willst du mitgucken?
Nee, hat keinen Bock.
Nee, die will jetzt auf den Schrank und schlafen gehen.
4 Minuten, gleich ist es soweit.
Ich bin echt gespannt.
Guck mal Leute, die Rakete läuft aus.
Leak, die Rakete leakt.
Chico, willst du wieder raus?
Okay Chico, ich mach dir die Tür wieder auf.
Ach, 3 Minuten.
Das ist der offizielle Space Extreme.
Jetzt geht's los.
Cute Rocket, genau.
Chat, wir müssen was machen.
Wir müssen Energie giffen, 10 Sekunden vor dem Start.
10 Sekunden bevor es losgeht, muss der ganze Chat Energie geben.
Dass es auch was wird.
Chat, es hängt von euch ab.
Wenn das nachher in die Hose geht und alle keine Energie gegift haben,
dann steht die NASA bei euch vor der Tür.
Ihr könnt noch warten, es dauert noch eine Minute.
Guck mal, Kryptag auch am Start.
Jolly Yoka, abonniert Twitch Prime.
Chat, noch nicht.
Ihr habt es doch an der Rakete gesehen.
Die Rakete läuft geradeaus.
10 Sekunden bevor es losgeht.
Okay, nachdem ihr so scharf drauf seid, können wir auch 15 Sekunden vorher anfangen.
Ich hoffe der Bauer hat auch die Rakete übertaktet vorher, dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Und geköpft und flüssig Metall drauf gemacht.
Das passt gut, oder?
Okay Leute, jetzt Energie giffen.
Allesamt Energie.
Ich finde das immer geil, wie langsam das Ding losfliegt.
Du denkst immer, es fällt um?
Ja laber nicht rum, warte erst mal bis wir hier oben sind.
Wir drücken dich bestimmt ganz gut in den Sitz.
Ich glaube der Musk sitzt jetzt daheim und schwitzt ganz schön.
Umso dünner die Atmosphäre wird, umso schneller geht das ja auch.
Der Lachs geht gut ab.
Moment.
Warum ist die Rakete schräg, wenn die Erde flach ist?
Das geht auch gar nicht.
Oh was jetzt? Ah jetzt sprengen sie das Ding ab, was dann wieder landet.
Wie schnell die ist, die wird noch eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Umso weniger Atmosphäre da ist, umso einfacher gehts ja.
Deswegen wird die auch immer schneller.
Die wird noch eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Der untere müsste eigentlich wieder landen.
Ich finde es halt hart, wie das Metall um das Triebwerk glüht.
Die sind einfach im Welt, aber das nicht mal in zwei Minuten da.
So hoch ist das ja nicht.
Ich glaube, wo ist die offizielle Grenze?
140 Kilometer oder so?
Es gibt doch so eine Grenze ab, wann das Weltall anfängt.
140 Kilometer oder so.
100 Kilometer, ich weiß gar irgendwie so.
Da außen ist es ziemlich kalt, aber dadurch, dass du wenig Atmosphäre hast,
kann dir die Wärme nicht richtig ableiten.
Du kannst ja Wärme nur gut ableiten, wenn du halt irgendwas hast, was leitet.
Aber da ist halt wenig was leitet drum herum.
Also es ist egal, dass da Minus drum herum ist.
Das ist heiß.
Wasserkühlung.
Ich sagte doch, die hätten den Bauer einfliegen sollen.
Der hätte krass eine Wasserkühlung dran gebaut.
Wie lange die fliegen, ich weiß nicht, wie lange es geht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich würde mal aus dem Bauch raus sagen,
so eine Viertelstunde oder so.
Was machen wir nun?
19 Stunden.
Was machen die da?
19 Stunden, echt?
Was machen die 19 Stunden da?
Fliegen.
Erstmal die ISS einholen.
Ja, okay, okay.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, die sind 20 Minuten, sind die da?
Die sitzen einfach drin und müssen nichts machen.
Ich weiß nicht, was die machen.
Aber egal, wenn es schief geht, sind die, die gearschen.
Naja, die ISS ist so viel weiter.
Ist die nicht weg?
Wie weit ist die weg?
500 Kilometer?
So weit ist das Ding nicht weg.
400 Kilometer, 500 Kilometer irgendwie.
Also, wenn es darum geht, wären die zur Hälfte schon da.
Aber ja klar, leuchtet ein.
Die müssen erst mal hinterherfliegen, aufholen und langsam hinfliegen.
Ja, das leuchtet ein, dass das ein bisschen dauert.
Ach guck mal, das ist das Ding, was landet hier, oder?
Das ist das Ding, was gerade wieder runterfliegt und landet.
Sind auf der ISS auch gerade Leute?
Wahrscheinlich, da sind immer Leute.
Das ist die erste Session.
Es wird die zweite Maschine ausgeliefert.
Wir werden kurz nach der Landung von Stage 1 schauen.
Eigentlich nur in ein paar Sekunden von einander.
Es ist so ein cooles Gesicht auf deiner linken Seite.
Sehen Bob und Doug auf Dragon.
Jetzt können Sie die Displays sehen, die sie jetzt selbst sehen.
Das ist die zweite Maschine.
Wir sind jetzt 25 Sekunden oder so weg vom Second Engine Cut-Off.
Das ist auch der Punkt, wo Bob und Doug ihre höchste G-Force erleben.
Wir sehen, dass die Hälfte auf Stage 1,8 aufsteigt.
Copy, Shannon.
Du hast Shannon gehört, also bedeutet das, dass sie in ihren letzten Abortzonen sind.
Sie könnten an dieser Stelle in Abortzonen sein oder auf dem Osten von Ireland landen.
Stand by für die zweite Maschine ausgeliefert.
Jetzt müssten sie ungefähr so schnell sein wie die ISS, oder?
Jetzt warten wir auf unsere erste Maschine, um den Weg zur Drohne zu machen.
Natürlich liebe ich Sie immer noch.
Jetzt landet das Ding erstmal.
Das ist der erste Falcon 9, der mit den Menschen in die Abortzonen fährt.
Was passiert bei Deploy?
Was deployen die da?
Die zweite Stufe, die Kapsel.
Die dritte Stufe, die dritte Stufe, die dritte Stufe.
Die dritte Stufe, die dritte Stufe.
Oh, jetzt erzählen sie uns was.
Na endlich ist Amerika wieder im Lower Orbit.
Also ganz ehrlich, das Wichtigste für mich an dieser Mission heute zum Gucken war ja auch, dass Amerika wieder im Orbit ist.
Ich freue mich schon die ganze Zeit darauf, dass ich denke, ja, Amerika ist wieder im Orbit, Alter.
Corona im Weltall.
Was, wer ist Raster da?
Genug.
Chat und alles nur, weil ihr Energie gegiftet habt.
Ohne euch hätte das nicht funktioniert.
Und bleibt ein alter sieben Monate, dankeschön. Exzellent, Subscription.
Sehr kenne ich es.
Wie schnell die jetzt schon sind, ja.
Also ich glaube da wohne ich irgendwo.
Was war dein längster Flug?
Ich glaube 5 Stunden oder so.
So, ein Tag für die Historischen Bücher. Wie ihr seht, haben wir ein Live Signal verloren.
Aber die Mission geht weiter und wir werden es über KSC senden, um live mit euch weiter zu verbreiten.
Daniel, das heißt Subscriber.
Dem Chat gefällt der Host, wie es aussieht.
Okay, das war's. Easy.
Nice. Okay, wir haben es überlebt, Leute.
Nice, cool, dass das geklappt hat.
Und die Übertragung, ich mein, auch wenn es nur 720p ist, war doch trotzdem ziemlich gut.
Okay, jetzt feiern sie sich alle noch ein bisschen.
Ja, also wir können heute leider nicht mitfliegen.
Ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt ganz froh, ich bleibe lieber hier.
Ich will da gar nicht mitfliegen, aber ich gucke gerne zu.
Aber es war nice, war nice zu sehen.
Ich hoffe euch hat der lange Stream heute gefallen, weil er relativ lange am Start.
Wenn unter ein oder anderen noch einen Twitch Prime übrig hat, würde ich mich natürlich sehr freuen, wenn da noch was geht.
Und spätestens morgen früh bin ich wieder am Start, so gegen 9.30, 10 Uhr oder so.
Und dann machen wir das übliche, was wir sonntags immer machen, also sprich eine Runde Aufwachstream.
Und morgen wieder ReactOS, ja, genau.
ReactOS ohne OS.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Fragen heute übersehen habe.
Wow, was ist denn hier los?
Mein Board spinnt rum.
ChrisPlays sagt, ich will Hentai im Weltall.
Da bist du bestimmt nicht der Einzige.
Kein Schimmer.
Kann Moskwal zum Mond fliegen? Können kann er bestimmt, ich weiß nicht ob er das freiwillig macht.
Ja, alles klar, ich bin mal weg, wir sehen uns, Autromusik brauchen wir noch.
Sonst können sich wieder Leute sagen, sie konnten jetzt nicht schlafen, weil ich keine Autromusik gemacht habe.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns bis morgen früh, see you, Tschüss.
Wir sehen uns bis morgen früh, see you, Tschüss.
Tschüss.